bien rebonjour à toutes et à tous nous
reprenons nos travaux cet après-midi
avec l'audition de Monsieur Luc Raymond
Président Directeur Général
d'électricité de France Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général merci
d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à participer à nos
travaux
c'est vrai que la nature des échanges
nous allons sûrement avoir cet
après-midi sera sûrement un peu
différente à la fois de celle que nous
avons avec vue U avec vos prédécesseurs
et de façon générale de l'objet de nos
travaux puisque on est un peu à cheval
entre le constat et qui devrait être
l'ouverture de nos travaux à savoir les
propositions néanmoins la cette audition
s'inscrit dans dans la continuité des
auditions auxquelles nous avons déjà pu
procéder avec
les groupes qui travaillent actuellement
au sujet énergétique je pense à
l'audition de Monsieur Patrick pouyanet
ou de Madame Catherine McGregor
votre audition parachève donc ce tour
d'horizon de ces groupes qui ont
profondément marqué l'histoire
énergétique de notre pays constituant
des atouts essentiels pour l'ensemble de
nos filières industriels et garantissant
aux Français l'accès à l'énergie la
Commission à plus particulièrement axé
ces auditions sur l'électricité
non sans avoir traité les autres sources
d'énergie mais vu les caractères
physiques particuliers de l'énergie et
les enjeux particuliers
que l'électricité a en matière
d'indépendance énergétique nous avons
notamment entendu deux de vos actuelles
collaborateurs messieurs Bensasson et
lesww
leurs auditions ont permis de faire un
tour relativement complet de la
situation et des perspectives des
différentes filières prises en charge au
niveau national et internationales par
EDF le nucléaire l'hydroélectricité les
autres énergies renouvelables sachant
que la position d'EDF selon ses
différentes filières notamment vis-à-vis
de concurrents potentiel sur le
territoire national est plutôt variable
les présidents d'honneur d'EDF nous ont
également fait l'honneur de venir nous
présenter leurs analyses le puzzle de
l'histoire énergétique de la France a pu
ainsi partiellement ce sordonner par
ailleurs nous avons écouté avec
attention les représentants des
syndicats siègents au sein du Comité
économique et social de votre entreprise
et ce de l'énergie représentative au
niveau national enfin la Commission a
auditionner les représentants des
différentes entités qui gravitent autour
de d'EDF certaines en étant même des
filiales ou des sociétés dans lesquelles
EDF est actionnaire framatum ourano
landra le CEA la SN l'IRSN RTE la creux
etc
dans le temps imparti à une commission
d'enquête nous avons voulu recueillir
des éléments d'information de l'amende
depuis la recherche à Laval des cycles
industriels du domaine de l'énergie plus
particulièrement du secteur nucléaire
les atouts de la filière ont été maintes
fois soulignés diversifiés ont été
identifiés qu'ils soient politiques
juridique financier technique mais aussi
de gouvernance
votre audition nous permettra donc
certainement d'y voir encore plus clair
en complément du rapport d'activité des
groupes publiés il y a une dizaine de
jours et en permettant à notre
commission de se projeter dans les mois
et les années à venir pour votre groupe
temporalité dans laquelle s'inscrire on
également les propositions qui émaneront
de notre travaux avant de vous laisser
la parole monsieur le Président il me
revient simplement de vous demander en
application de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des assemblée
membres parlementaires de vous demander
de bien vouloir prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité et rien que la
vérité en conséquence de quoi je vous
prie de bien vouloir lever la main
droite et dire je le jure je le jure
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
je vous laisse donc la parole pour un
propos introductif
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés je vous remercie
de me donner l'occasion de m'exprimer
devant votre commission d'enquête comme
vous l'avez rappelé mon arrivée à la
tête de DF est récente et elle me
conduit à naturellement à parler
davantage de l'avenir que du passé sur
lequel vous avez auditionné mes
prédécesseurs et je vous remercie au
passage du travail de votre commission
d'enquête parce que elle m'a permis
aussi
de de compléter mon savoir de
l'entreprise au travers de la lecture et
voir de l'audition de beaucoup de
personnes que vous avez auditionnées
depuis trois mois à la tête du groupe
EDF j'ai consacré une grande partie de
mon temps aux rencontres de terrain aux
échanges avec les équipes de tous les
métiers avec nos partenaires industriels
et nos clients partout j'ai été
impressionné par le niveau de compétence
et d'engagement des collaborateurs du
groupe alors qu'il traverse vous le
savez une situation particulièrement
difficile le marché de l'énergie vient
de subir une série de chocs avec les
conséquences de la pandémie de la
vigueur de la reprise économique qui a
suivi puis de la guerre en Ukraine avec
l'arrêt progressif des principales voies
de livraison de gaz à l'Europe et
l'organisation du marché européen de
l'électricité et du gaz n'était pas
totalement conçu pour faire face à des
chocs successifs d'une telle amplitude
sur la demande l'offre et les prix des
décisions exceptionnelles ont été prises
pour faire face à l'urgence
elles ont permis de garantir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement malgré la pénurie de
gaz et les faillites de certains
fournisseurs et parallèlement un
processus de concertation est maintenant
engagé au niveau européen sur les
besoins de réforme de l'organisation du
marché donc ça c'est pour le marché dans
son contexte plus général et dans le
même temps EDF a été confronté en 2022 à
la plus grande crise énergétique depuis
1973 et à la plus grande crise
opérationnelle depuis sa création la
découverte du phénomène de corrosion
sous contrainte les arrêts de réacteurs
pour contrôler les réparations qu'à la
sûreté nucléaire est la priorité absolue
de l'exploitant EDF ont entraîné une
baisse de la production en 2022 à un
niveau jamais atteint dans l'histoire du
parc nucléaire
totalisant infini et 279 terawattheure
parallèlement la sécheresse qui a sévit
en 2022 amputé également la production
hydraulique dans des proportions
exceptionnelles pas seulement en France
mais dans la plupart des pays européens
heureusement la mobilisation et le
professionnalisme de toutes les équipes
du groupe EDF ont été à la hauteur de
l'enjeu l'ensemble des capacités
techniques d'EDF et de la filière
nucléaire a été mobilisée sur la
corrosion sous contrainte pour
identifier caractériser définir les
solutions puis industrialiser leur
déploiement avant de reconnecter les
réacteurs arrêtés conformément au plan
de marche sur lequel l'entreprise
s'était engagée et je veux saluer cette
mobilisation générale dans le même temps
les autres moyens de production
hydrauliques thermiques
on fait preuve d'une disponibilité tout
à fait exceptionnelle nos clients ont
également répondu présent à l'appel que
nous avions lancé avec le gouvernement
en faveur de la sobriété et du
déplacement horaire de la consommation
avec la campagne je baisse j'éteins je
décale tout ceci a permis de sécuriser
les moments les plus critiques du
passage de l'hiver une quinzaine de
réacteurs ont été recoupées au réseau
entre début novembre et début janvier et
nous avons passé une vague de froid
intense mi -décembre avec des
températures de 5 degrés sous les
normales nous voyons désormais la fin de
l'hiver avec confiance même si
évidemment il faut rester très vigilant
et nos équipes continuent de travailler
sans relâche pour assurer la meilleure
disponibilité de la production
naturellement sur le plan financier
cette année a eu des conséquences la
baisse de la production d'électricité et
les mesures régulateurs exceptionnelles
mises en place pour limiter la hausse
des prix pour les consommateurs français
ont fortement pénalisé les résultats du
groupe en le conduisant à acheter de
l'électricité à des prix très élevés
pour
maintenir
la fourniture à nos différents clients
ainsi malgré une perte forte hausse du
chiffre d'affaires grâce à cet effet
pris la marge c'est-à-dire les Bida
désolée si j'utilise quelques termes
financiers de temps à autre est en être
utile
totalisant moins 5 milliards pour 2022
par rapport à 18 milliards positifs en
2021 ainsi que le résultat net courant
qui est de -12,7 milliards en 2022 par
rapport à + 4,7 milliards en 2021 tandis
que l'endettement augmente de 21,5
milliards pour totaliser
64,5 milliards d'euros
naturellement en 2023 le redressement de
l'entreprise et la priorité absolue
commencer par le redressement
opérationnel mais qui sera suivi du
redressement financier avec pour
objectif d'atteindre un débit dedans
donc une marge
significativement supérieur à celui de
2021 qui était de 18 milliards d'euros
et de maintenir notre endettement
financier net rapporté à les Biden en
dessous d'un ratio de 3 fois qui est
celui que
auquel nous sommes engagés auprès des
marchés financiers
EDF a donc connu en 2022 comme
l'ensemble des marchés d'énergie à
chaque un choc sans précédent et grâce à
la mobilisation de tous je crois
profondément que des f est en train de
se relever de ce choc
même s'il reste de nombreux de défis à
court terme à relever je pense que
l'entreprise doit maintenant se tourner
à nouveau vers l'avenir et dans ce
contexte je voudrais évoquer avec vous
les conditions qui permettent qui sont
nécessaires pour que EDF soit en mesure
de répondre aux attentes de la France en
matière de souveraineté énergétique dans
le cas des lignes stratégiques fixées
par le Président de la République lors
de son discours de Belfort début 2022
chaque industrie a des cycles après une
période de relativement plus faible
investissement lorsque le parc de
production était très récent EDF a connu
une reprise progressive de ces
investissements depuis près de 15 ans
ils ont été matérialisés par le
lancement du grand carénage par
Flamanville et par d'autres
investissements et par un investissement
dans les renouvelables aussi évidemment
qui a été soutenu tous les analystes le
disent qu'ils soient ceux de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie ce de RTE ou
ceux d'EDF pour maîtriser le
réchauffement climatique une
accélération des usages de l'électricité
est nécessaire et induit un besoin accru
de production d'électricité décarbonée
dans les années à venir de toute forme
nucléaire hydraulique solaire et éolien
l'ensemble de ces formes de production
concurrents à un mix électrique qui est
de nature à assurer la robustesse et la
compétitivité de la fourniture d'une
électricité décarbonée à l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens la mission d'EDF c'est
de se préparer à répondre à cette
demande tout en continuant de fourchir
chaque jour une électricité des
carbonées compétitive elle est d'ores et
déjà des carbonée à 91% ce qui est
évidemment un record mondial
donc notre mission c'est de pouvoir
continuer dans cette direction en
continuant de décarboner pour être au
rendez-vous le groupe aborde désormais
un nouveau cycle d'investissement de
plus grande ampleur
nous entrons dans la phase la plus
importante du grand carénage du parc
existant avec chaque année un nombre
croissant de visites décennales des
réacteurs de 30 et 40 ans qui vont
permettre la prolongation du parc
nucléaire en procédant à des
remplacements de gros composants il y a
des améliorations significatives de
sûreté lors des de ces fameuses visites
décennales 3 et 4 dans le jargon local
baptisé vd3 et vd4
conformément au cap fixé par le Comité
de politique nucléaire nous travaillons
dans la perspective d'amener le parc
nucléaire a fonctionné en toute sûreté
au delà de 60 ans donc c'est un premier
ensemble d'investissement tout à fait
structurant pour le groupe le
parallèlement s'engage la phase
industrielle du programme de nouveau
nucléaire avec un premier ensemble de 6
EPR 2 soit une capacité de production
supplémentaire de près de 10 GW un débat
public portant sur le premier réacteur
prévu à panli en Seine-Maritime est en
cours
et si la mesure figurant dans le projet
de loi nucléaire en cours d'examen par
votre assemblée sont retenus les
premiers travaux pourraient débuter
début 2024 nous préparons également
l'avenir en développant un nouveau type
de réacteurs de plus petite taille
baptisé new hard et dont les gains en
termes de complexité simplification et
de et la possibilité d'en fabriquer des
modules directement en usine peuvent
permettre de répondre à d'autres types
de besoins que ceux qui sont
adaptés pour des gros réacteurs enfin un
mix électrique décarboné repose
également sur des moyens de production
renouvelables hydrauliques et éolien et
solaires dont les investissements les
plus récents je pense à l'éolien en mer
apporte sur le réseau des capacités
nouvelles comme les 480 MW de que nous
avons récemment connecté au réseau à
Saint-Nazaire enfin évidemment il y a
des moyens thermiques décarbonés qui
apportent un complément précieux au
réseau et à l'équilibre en général
lorsqu'il s'agit d'avoir de la
flexibilité de pointe notamment donc
c'est sur l'ensemble de ces dispositions
que le groupe EDF doit maintenant entrer
dans un cycle d'investissement nouveau
pour réaliser ce grand programme
d'investissement essentiel à
souveraineté énergétique de la France
évidemment le groupe EDF a besoin d'un
outil industriel performant
des compétences humaines à la hauteur
des enjeux et d'un modèle économique
robuste sur le long terme
avec l'intégration de framatum au sein
du groupe EDF il y a quelques années
bientôt celle des turbines arabels le
groupe EDF dispose d'un outil industriel
en capacité de concevoir de fabriquer et
de maintenir les éléments clés de son
parc nucléaire toutes les entreprises de
la filière organisées au sein du gifen
réunissent une gamme de savoir-faire
exceptionnels et travail pour beaucoup à
l'export comme pour le parc français
dans le domaine du renouvelable la
situation industrielle est plus
contrastée la domination asiatique est
une réalité en Europe dans le solaire
seuls les États-Unis parviennent à
développer une filière de modules
photovoltaïques avec une politique
industrielle très volontariste pour la
fabrication des éoliennes en mer en
revanche nous avons une industrie qui
s'est développée sur le territoire
français les 80 machines installées par
EDF sur le parc de Naser comme celle que
nous installerons prochainement à Fécamp
et au large de Ouistreham sont fabriqués
dans les usines de Saint-Nazaire du
Havre et de Cherbourg
en termes de compétences le groupe EDF
comme les entreprises de la filière
disposent d'un excellent niveau de
qualité j'ai pu m'en apercevoir me le
confirmer à moi-même c'est des choses
que je savais déjà par ma présence dans
un certain nombre d'activités qui avait
très nucléaire j'ai pu le confirmer par
beaucoup de visites sur le terrain
depuis quelques mois
sauf exception nous n'avons pas constaté
de manque en niveau de compétence
l'enjeu concerne la quantité pas la
qualité et donc pour nous lancer dans
les besoins des années à venir qui sont
considérables nous devons nous adresser
au sujet de quantité de compétences sur
la base de qualité de compétences qui
sont très solides
il s'agit d'une préoccupation commune à
de nombreux secteurs industriels le
secteur industriel dont je viens qui
était adjacent au secteur du nucléaire
connaissait les mêmes difficultés
peut-être moins visible contenu de sa de
sa taille plus relative par rapport à
l'économie française donc il s'agit bien
d'un phénomène de société et d'une
difficulté plus générale de l'activité
industrielle dans nos pays pas seulement
de la France auquel nous devons apporter
des solutions dans les mois et les
années qui viennent pour répondre à
l'enjeu d'investissement auquel nous
sommes appelés et pour cela il faut
commencer par attirer les talents les
formations existent elles ne sont juste
pas suffisamment remplies donc il faut
commencer par appeler les talents les
attirer dans les formations techniques
leur donner envie de pratiquer ces
métiers pendant une carrière ou un bout
de carrière et c'est bien l'enjeu auquel
nous sommes appelés pour lequel
l'entreprise est d'ores et déjà
mobilisée alors dans le domaine du
nucléaire
la filière s'est organisée en lançant un
travail de recensement des besoins
métiers par métiers et d'adéquation avec
les formations existantes en
spécialisation et en volume ça s'appelle
le programme match parallèlement
l'Université des métiers du nucléaire
créé en avril 2021
par le csfn EDF et les grands donneurs
d'ordre de la filière France industrie
lui-même Pôle Emploi bref l'ensemble de
l'écosystème industriel français
concours à cette université des métiers
du district du nucléaire et là pour
mission de dynamiser les dispositifs de
formation au niveau régional et national
pour apporter les bonnes réponses aux
besoins identifiés par la filière
au-delà des compétences ce qui doit être
renforcé dans la perspective d'une
montée en puissance industrielle de
série c'est la capacité de la filière à
travailler en intégration de bout en
bout
nous avons depuis 20 ans une activité
industrielle existante dans le domaine
du nucléaire ce qui change quand on
regarde vers l'avenir c'est qu'il faut
tout faire à l'échelle industrielle
c'est-à-dire que nous avons nous avons
un réacteur en construction sur le sol
national nous en aurons plusieurs nous
avons plusieurs réacteurs à l'échelle
internationale donc c'est bien un enjeu
de monter en puissance industrielle de
l'ensemble d'une filière qui est devant
nous
pour y parvenir il faut optimiser le
temps collectif comme on le fait
généralement dans l'industrie et ce
temps collectif chez EDF il s'appelle le
temps métal c'est une expression commune
dans l'entreprise qui désigne le temps
qui est directement dédié à la machine
et donc nous devons optimiser le temps
métal collectif nous devons disposer de
processus et d'outils homogène au
travers de l'ensemble de la filière
notamment d'outils digitaux qui
permettent de faire gagner du temps à
tout le monde
nous devons évidemment tirer l'ensemble
de l'expérience de Flamanville 3 comme
un apprentissage collectif
sur tout ce que nous devons améliorer à
partir de Flamanville 3 avant de se
lancer dans la série EPR 2 et en tenant
compte également des autres retours
d'expérience sur inclipoint et sur Tyson
et old auto
depuis ma prise de fonction j'ai lancé
avec l'ensemble des dirigeants du groupe
4 chantier destinés à améliorer la
performance opérationnelle le premier
est précisément sur le temps métal tous
les collaborateurs depuis les centrales
le premier jour un Flamanville jusqu'au
bureau d'études tous ont partagé avec
moi la nécessité d'améliorer le temps
efficace
il s'agit de lever des complexités
inutiles des rigidités administratives
internes ou collectives les deux
existent
d'améliorer l'organisation du travail et
d'accélérer les décisions voilà tout ce
que recouvre ce chantier en métal que
nous avons engagé il y a quelques
semaines le deuxième concerne nos outils
digitaux nous avons évidemment beaucoup
d'outils digitaux et certains parmi ceux
que j'ai trouvé sont vraiment à la
pointe mais
nous sommes 20 ans après le début du 21e
siècle nous parlons de créer des objets
qui vont demeurer opérationnel
potentiellement jusqu'au de 2100 je
pense que nos lointain successeur nous
demanderons si jamais ce n'était pas le
cas où se trouve la maquette digitale
complète des objets que nous créons
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir assurer la
maintenance dans 80 ans sans avoir à
retrouver la documentation papier donc
c'est une exigence que nous devons nous
fixer à nous-mêmes que d'entrer dans
cette nouvelle génération avec une
plateforme digitale complète qui
permette le bout en bout
le travail sur l'ensemble de la durée de
vie et puis évidemment le partage et
l'intégration qui sont les éléments
absolument clés de la réussite d'un
programme de cette ampleur sur le plan
sur le plan industriel le troisième
chantier que nous avons lancé concerne
évidemment les compétences dont j'ai
déjà parlé
notamment pour attirer les talents et
encore une fois le problème n'est pas la
qualité des compétences ça n'est pas
l'existence des formations c'est le fait
d'attirer les volontés de travailler
dans ce monde
et enfin le dernier car il n'est pas de
performance sans mesure consiste à
améliorer le pilotage de notre
performance en sachant précisément ce
que nous cherchons à atteindre au fur et
à mesure où nous engageons de nouveaux
projets
l'objectif de ces chantiers est simple
c'est donner à nos équipes les méthodes
les outils qui permettront de gagner une
meilleure disponibilité du parc
nucléaire grâce une parfaite exécution
des arrêts pour maintenance lourdes de
permettre à nos grands projets neufs de
se dérouler avec un maximum de
répétitions et un minimum d'aléa afin
d'atteindre une cadence industrielle
nous y parviendrons nous n'y
parviendrons pas en un an je
prends cette précaution
mais je suis convaincu que nous aurons
des résultats dès 2023 et je veux dire
vraiment ma confiance dans la compétence
et la motivation des équipes de DF et de
l'ensemble de la filière pour atteindre
cette ambition d'excellence
enfin je voudrais dire que la réussite
de cette grande ambition industrielle
pour EDF suppose un modèle économique
qui vise la continuité de son parc
nucléaire et donc permet son
exploitation sa maintenant et son
renouvellement
ça peut paraître paradoxal de mentionner
le modèle économique d'EDF dans une
période de les prix de l'électricité
sont historiquement haut et où
malheureusement par une malheureuse
conjugaison de facteurs EDF à des
résultats historiquement bas mais
indépendamment des circonstances de 2022
il est nécessaire de reposer le modèle
économique d'EDF sur le nucléaire à
l'aube de la nouvelle phase
d'investissement qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité du discours de Belfort du
président de la République et en tenant
compte des leçons de la crise
énergétique
je voudrais revenir sur un sujet qui
revient régulièrement
dans les mots d'EDF et dans les dans les
commentaires portant sur EDF qui celui
de la reine
depuis 10 ans eDF n'a en réalité pas
d'autres choix que de vendre son
électricité soit à un prix administratif
ne correspondant pas à sa réalité
économique qui s'appelle la reine soit à
un prix de marché reflétant en réalité
le prix du gaz
qui n'a pas davantage de lien avec sa
réalité économique
donc les règles qui s'appliquent à EDF
aux vies oblige donc la plupart du temps
à une combinaison de ces deux prix
cela permis de protéger client d'une
partie de la volatilité des prix du gaz
c'est une réalité pour le marché
français
compléter dans une année particulière
comme 2022 où ce début d'année 2023 par
des mesures prises par le gouvernement
le bouclier tarifaire et l'amortisseur
dans les circonstances exceptionnelles
que nous vivons mais ça n'a pas permis
de faire émerger des investissements
concurrents permettant de
de compléter les moyens de production en
France et cela aussi conduit à affaiblir
les finances de DF sur cette décennie
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
toujours qualifié depuis mes auditions
devant votre assemblée avant même d'être
nommé dans ce rôle toujours qualifier la
reine de dispositif à bout de souffle et
je pense que parmi les conditions du
succès futur de DF il y a le fait de
réinventer ce dispositif nous disposons
bien sûr d'une électricité décarbonée
compétitive depuis 20 ans cette
production a permis beaucoup de choses
d'abord en fixant des tarifs réglementés
de vente puis un prix administré au
travers de la reine la France a maintenu
des prix de fournitures qui sont bas
pour le marché français et c'est
toujours le cas quand vous les comparer
à d'autres territoires européens
le fait que les prix puissent être
suffisamment bas à aussi permis pendant
cette décennie de
de lever une fiscalité spécifique sur
les factures des clients qui est la CSPE
et qui est destiné à financer à
accélérer le développement du parc
renouvelable et accélérer ainsi comme
c'était souhaitable leur développement
sans peser excessivement sur les
factures des consommateurs
tout ceci a été possible dans un cycle
de 20 ans pendant lequel un parc
nucléaire récent
produisait à plein régime et avec des
besoins d'investissement complémentaires
limité
comme je l'indiqué nous entrons dans une
nouvelle ère dans laquelle
l'investissement électrique est plus que
jamais nécessaire dans le renouvelable
le nucléaire les réseaux
les technologies renouvelables
aujourd'hui ont gagné en compétitivité
grâce à leur industrialisation elles
vont pouvoir continuer leur
développement et prendre une côte par
importante des investissements
nécessaires en ayant besoin de beaucoup
moins de soutien public qu'il y a
quelques années à l'origine de ces
technologies la pérennisation du parc
nucléaire et la construction nucléaire
neuve indispensable pour un mix
énergétique décarboné équilibré et
compétitif comme l'ont montré les
travaux du RTE dans les futurs
énergétiques 2050 nécessitent des
investissements qui doivent eux aussi
trouver leur équilibre économique de
long terme ce mix compétitif qui est
résilient et protecteur par rapport à la
volatilité des prix du gaz nous devons
le préparer dans des conditions
économiques soutenables ces conditions
ne sont pas permise par des règles
définies il y a 10 ans sur la base d'une
valeur comptable historique et d'un prix
de marché volatile
le marché de l'électricité européen
n'est pas la cause de ces mots il permet
des règles d'échanges d'électricité à
court terme dont toute l'Europe
bénéficie y compris la France tous les
jours en exportant ou en important de
l'électricité aux heures où nous en
avons soit trop soit pas assez
et ça nous permet donc une répartition
efficace de l'électricité à l'échelle
européenne mais ce marché tel qu'il est
défini aujourd'hui est incomplet il ne
permet pas de donner la visibilité de
long terme nécessaire à l'investissement
et il est trop sujet pour les
consommateurs à la volatilité associée
au prix du gaz c'est la raison pour
laquelle ces règles doivent être
complétées pour faire émerger une
capacité de contractualisation à long
terme et de donner dans ce cadre une
meilleure visibilité au consommateurs
comme au producteur et une meilleure
protection contre les fluctuations de
court terme des discussions sont en
cours à l'échelle du marché européen et
j'espère sincèrement qu'elle permettront
de faire émerger un consensus européen
pour adapter les règles de marché
en intégrant cette nécessité du long
terme qui est vraiment une condition de
notre succès collectif
dans un tel cadre EDF pourra renouveler
son parc nucléaire et ses autres moyens
de production tout en veillant à la
compétitivité économique de la France
mais le temps où le nucléaire est
capable de payer pour l'ensemble
de la collectivité y compris des
dimensions qui sont éloignées du
nucléaire doivent venir à sa fin car le
nucléaire doit maintenant être en mesure
d'investir pour son propre avenir
la souveraineté est un enjeu absolument
majeur et nous avons vu pendant le covid
depuis un an avec l'invasion l'Ukraine
par la Russie à quel point les
dépendances de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement nous rendaient
vulnérables à des événements externes
nous devons continuer de consolider
notre souveraineté ce qui est très
largement le cas dans notre filière
nucléaire mais sur un certain nombre de
domaines clés de notre système
économique il n'y a pas de souveraineté
dans quelques domaines que ce soit sans
indépendance énergétique EDF dispose de
nombreux atouts pour garantir la nation
c'est indépendance énergétique tout en
permettant de préparer la décarbonation
de notre économie c'est dans ce contexte
et avec cette ambition que j'ai pris mes
fonctions je me suis attaché à prendre
la mesure de l'entreprise et de ses
défis au contact de nos collaborateurs
la première ministre m'a demandé de
faucolieriser mon action sur la
production le redressement financier et
la montée en puissance industrielle par
les investissements je m'y emploie avec
l'ensemble des collaborateurs du Groupe
tous les jours j'ai commencé
conformément à la demande de la première
ministre l'élaboration de la feuille de
route du groupe que je présenterai d'ici
l'été et elle visera à tracer les
priorités du groupe dans ces différents
métiers pour assurer sa réussite en tant
qu'opérateur de système électrique voilà
ce que je voulais dire en quelques mots
d'introduction monsieur le Président et
je serai naturellement heureux de
répondre à vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Directeur Général pour ce propos
introductif qui balaye
largement les préoccupations que nous
évoquons au fil de l'eau dans dans nos
auditions j'aurai une première question
qui relève d'un d'un sentiment
qui est celui de la somme des auditions
que nous avons pu organiser
[Musique]
qui est que
l'Union européenne n'aime pas trop EDF
une petite conclusion que je peux tirer
des échanges que que nous avons eu
notamment avec vos prédécesseurs et que
les règles successives qui ont été
imposées à la France par l'Union
européenne
systématiquement visé à fragiliser en
partie votre entreprise comment est-ce
que vous percevez cela et surtout quelle
est la stratégie que vous entendez
mettre en place pour
organiser l'influence d'EDF et donc de
la politique électrique française au
niveau de Bruxelles
merci monsieur le Président
je suis trop trop récent dans le poste
pour pour qualifier ce que vous vous
dites en termes de code d'amour
en revanche je pense que
nous sommes dans un dans un espace
européen dans lequel l'ensemble des pays
européens ont décidé il y a plus de 20
ans de créer un marché de l'électricité
unique ce marché a un certain nombre de
règles
qui ont été adoptés par tous les pays
compris la France et et l'Union
européenne et là pour
faire appliquer les règles et en même
temps contribuer à leur évolution je
pense que quand nous sommes en
discussion entre la France et l'Europe
c'est cela qu'il faut rappeler du côté
de l'Europe du côté de la France je
pense qu'il faut rappeler que la France
est le seul pays de l'Union à avoir fait
un pari stratégique il y a 50 ans
10 ans pour réduire notre dépendance aux
imports
d'origine carbonée nous allons
développer une filière industrielle
nucléaire qui nous permet d'être
autonome et des carbonés en produits et
compétitifs en production électrique et
donc évidemment il y a une différence de
vision qui s'exprime de longue date je
crois c'est ce que mes prédécesseurs ont
expliqué devant votre devant votre
commission sur
oui nous souhaitons avoir un marché de
l'électricité qui permette l'échange
d'électricité à court terme ça c'est la
réalité dont bénéficie la France aussi
mais nous souhaitons que l'effort
spécifiques le choix stratégique qui a
été fait par notre pays en matière de
mix énergétique continue de bénéficier à
nos concitoyens
ce qu'il faut c'est trouver un chemin
qui permet de concilier ces deux
objectifs
ce chemin aujourd'hui il a trouvé une
conciliation qui s'appelle la reine
puisque la reine permet de garantir une
forme de d'accès au prix de
l'électricité nucléaire aux
consommateurs
je crois et c'est ce que j'ai dit qu'il
faut trouver un autre chemin pour le
futur parce que ce chemin qui passe par
la reine il est à bout de souffle parce
qu'il finit il pèse sur l'entreprise
je ne crois pas que ce soit par
une vision négative de l'entreprise que
ce chemin a été trouvé sur l'arène ce
chemin était trouvé sur la reine parce
que c'était celui que la France et
l'Europe pouvait trouver pour résoudre
les intérêts parfois divergents qui peut
y avoir entre avoir un seul marché
européen et en même temps protéger le
marché français ou garantir au marché
français la compétitivité acquise au
travers d'un investissement de très long
terme dans le parc nucléaire
donc ce que nous disons à ce stade c'est
que la façon dont écart de vision a été
résorbée depuis une dizaine d'années
doit maintenant trouver une autre façon
pour continuer de garantir la
compétitivité future de l'énergie
produite en France
et continue de s'inscrire dans un marché
européen qui par ailleurs bénéficient à
l'ensemble de l'Europe et à la France je
pense que si cet hiver parmi d'autres
hivers le marché européen n'avait pas
été aussi fluide n'avait pas été aussi
liquide en termes de accès à
l'électricité nous aurions eu nous
français des moments plus difficiles
j'en viens justement à la reine
la contextualisation qu'on a essayé
d'opérer dans le cas de nos auditions
nous a permis de d'identifier un certain
nombre de d'impensés au moment de la
mise en place de l'arène notamment le
fait qu'il puisse y avoir de façon
durable des des prix de marché inférieur
à l'arène et donc que ça génère une
espèce de droit d'option pour l'acheteur
ça nous a permis aussi de nous rappeler
qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
pensées de la reine notamment la
nécessité d'un mécanisme de révision des
tarifs d'une discussion autour des
volumes qui n'ont jamais été mobilisés
donc j'entends parfaitement et
rapport dira sûrement si on partage en
grande partie la préoccupation
d'imaginer un autre système pour le
futur mais il y a un pas de temps de
court terme entre la situation
d'aujourd'hui qui génère des déficits à
coups de milliards annuels pour EDF et
l'après arène qui est encore quelques
mois à tenir comment est-ce que vous
envisagez c'est c'est moi ou petites
années et l'évolution de ce système à
règle constante
je crois que de ce point de vue
l'élément le plus nouveau et le plus
important c'est que l'Europe a enclenché
une discussion collective sur l'avenir
du marché
et donc ça ça ouvre des perspectives
potentielles puisque l'ensemble des
acteurs du marché européen ont été
consultés il y a maintenant quelques
semaines par la Commission européenne
sur la vision de marché qu'il convient
d'avoir pour le futur en demande à des
propositions maintenant à chacun de
soumettre leur propre vue sur comment le
marché pouvait s'organiser dans le futur
je ne sais pas où emmènera ces
discussions puisque la Commission est en
face de dépouillement de l'ensemble de
cette consultation mais c'est engagé à
revenir rapidement vers le conseil des
ministres européens de l'énergie avec
une proposition si comme je l'entends
comme je le crois la Commission entend
le message assez largement porté par
l'ensemble des opérateurs et des
gouvernements européens en faveur d'une
vision de long terme pour compléter
l'existence du marché de court terme je
crois que nous devrions pouvoir trouver
dans ce cadre-là une capacité de former
des règles pour le marché français qui
permettent de répondre aux
préoccupations exprimées de longue date
par
les nos concitoyens et par l'opérateur
EDF pour avoir une vision stable de long
terme soutenable de long terme en
matière de formation des prix de
l'électricité ça peut trouver
différentes formes sur le plan technique
sur lequel il est trop tôt je pense pour
pour rentrer dans les détails techniques
et les commentaires mais je crois que la
direction générale qui est prise à la
fois
du côté des autorités communautaires et
de la plupart des États membres et
d'appeler de leurs vœux un mouvement des
règles de marché qui permettent
l'émergence d'une forme de
contractualisation de long terme qui
permettent de rendre les consommateurs
et les producteurs moins vulnérables aux
aléas des prix de court terme et de
former des conditions d'investissement
qui sont beaucoup plus stables
est-ce qu'il est aujourd'hui impossible
de faire du contrat de long terme
c'est pas impossible mais c'est
fortement restreint
c'est fortement restreint pour tout un
tas de raisons que je pourrais lister si
vous le souhaitez c'est pas impossible
il y a un certain nombre de conditions
ou de secteur sur lequel le contrat de
long terme est possible par exemple sur
les renouvelables mais c'est quand même
assez fortement découragé
de financement
d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler
d'une part le besoin de financement du
nouveau nucléaire et de ce qui
l'accompagne
si c'est un chiffre qui circule ces
dernières semaines et pas toujours très
précis et peut-être en parallèle aussi
le besoin de financement pour les
énergies renouvelables sur le même pas
de temps
alors sur le nucléaire je peux vous
donner un ordre de grandeur qui qui
consomme 6 EPR et il faut toujours être
prudent sur comment on qualifie les les
gros chiffres parce que ils ont tendance
à bouger et quand à grossi bouge il
devient beaucoup plus gros encore donc
on parle d'un ordre de grandeur de 51
milliards pour 6 EPM
comme s'ils étaient construits à date
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on calcule cette
ordre de grandeur
ce qui est un gros chiffre évidemment
et mais c'est un ordre de grandeur
d'investissement pour les 10 GW dont on
parle qui est qui est un ordre de
grandeur classique entre guillemets
pour le renouvelable je serai en peine
de vous donner un ordre de grandeur
complet parce que par définition le
montant d'investissement dans le
renouvelable dépendra du nombre de
projets qui se développe et de la
capacité à les mener à bien et aussi du
résultat des appels d'offres par
technologie qui seront réalisés mais on
parle je crois on parle de d'ordre de
grandeur similaire au total sur la
totalité des investissements nécessaires
pour être capable
d'engendrer la production électrique
dans le pays a besoin avec une
électrification des usages qui
augmentent
donc un ordre de grandeur en besoin de
financement du même ordre que pour le
niveau nucléaire pour une capacité
installée
qui est plus faible aujourd'hui c'est
plus faible aujourd'hui
financement qui financera une capacité
de production de quel ordre du mémoire
aussi ça je sais pas vous dire
c'est vrai que c'est des sujets qui sont
un peu déséquilibrés dans la discussion
qu'on a on entend beaucoup ce que
Coutras le nouveau nucléaire on entend
assez peu ce que Coutras le reste oui
parce qu'en fait le renouvelable se
développe projet après projet et donc il
fait l'objet de moins de planification
je pense
[Musique]
il y a en cours le grand carénage mais
trois avaient des quatre qui va qui va
se poursuivre
deux questions
quelle est la méthode après ce grand
carénage vidé trois vv4 puisque on a vu
au cours des échanges que nous avons eu
qu'il y avait l'enjeu de passer au
palier suivant qui est celui des deux
trois quatre décennies qui suivent
et
deuxième question subsidiaire est-ce
qu'il y a un enjeu technique
étudié sur l'augmentation de puissance
des réacteurs à capacité constante
installée
sur votre premier point nous sommes en
train de commencer une discussion avec
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire sur la
façon dont nous allons aborder justement
ce cet horizon de temps dépassant les 50
ans justement pour caler la méthode donc
la méthode est
va être discuté dans les mois qui
viennent avec l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire donc c'est un travail qui
commence avec précisément la volonté de
se projeter plus loin et de ne pas
simplement examiner les problématiques
de prolongation de durée de vie à chaque
visite des Sénats donc c'est un travail
qui commence et qui va nous occuper une
bonne partie de l'année
sur sur votre deuxième question j'avoue
que je n'ai pas la réponse je ne sais
pas si nous serions capables d'augmenter
la puissance des réacteurs déjà en
fonctionnement la meilleure façon
d'augmenter les ce que l'on retire des
réacteurs et c'est vraiment tout l'objet
de notre travail aujourd'hui c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il produisent plus
souvent c'est à dire qu'il soit connecté
au réseau le plus longtemps possible et
qu'à chaque fois que pour des raisons de
maintenance ou parfois des raisons
fortuites nous sommes conduits à les
arrêter le temps d'arrêt soit le plus
court possible l'augmentation de la
puissance elle-même est vraiment d'un
effet secondaire mais le là où il faut
vraiment faire porter l'effort c'est sur
notre capacité à garder les réacteurs
connectés au réseau la plus grande
partie du temps
et c'est vraiment tout l'objet de tout
le travail de DFS en ce moment et de
l'ensemble de la filière
alors justement la façon la question
précédente sur la préparation de l'après
grand l'après vd3 vd4
la première ministre lors de son
discours sur la stratégie énergétique et
la prononcer à l'Assemblée nationale il
y a quelques semaines
indiquait réfléchir avec EDF et la SN à
identifier les réacteurs qui
s'arrêteront à 50 ans
est-ce que c'est dans ce sens là que
vous travaillez ou est-ce que c'est dans
le sens qui est expliqué au grand public
à savoir
identifier la façon dont on fait passer
les réacteurs à plus de 60 ans nous
sommes un opérateur électrique qui veut
opérer en toute sûreté donc nous
rejoignons le souhait de la première
ministre qui est de faire le travail
pour identifier tous ceux qui peuvent
travailler en toute sûreté évidemment
nous avons le souhait de faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent tous continuer de
travailler en toute sûreté
merci pour cette précision
au titre du nouveau nucléaire
il y a aussi l'enjeu des ce que
maintenant tout le monde appelle les SMS
pour reprendre un acronyme anglais
faire ça à l'Assemblée nationale
quel est votre vision en la matière de
moyens réacteurs
[Rires]
en inversant l'ordre des mots du coup
quel est du coup la vision que vous
aviez tant en matière de montage de
filière que de délai pour cette filière
parce que
même New World pour l'instant ensemble
une promesse à l'état des Bauche et pas
encore de
plan de réalisation industriel voilà
quelle est la vision que vous en avez
j'ajoute la conjugaison de cela sur les
technologies est-ce qu'il faut faire le
pari d'un seul type New World ou est-ce
qu'il faut imaginer travailler sur
d'autres prototypes le cas échéant peut
être des prototypes d'une autre
technologie que que le rep
merci beaucoup alors donc nous sommes
dans une phase qui évidemment est plus
préliminaire que dans le cas d'un projet
de réacteur de grande puissance dérivée
de l'EPR donc
l'enjeu pour nous et de d'arriver à
structurer un programme New World
dans les mois qui viennent
et de le développer en très peu d'années
pour pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il puisse
être proposé
commercialement et développé pas
seulement en France mais à
l'international parce que nous croyons
qu'il y a un véritable marché pour ce
type de réacteur à l'international
tout début de la prochaine décennie
il y a
dans ce projet un choix qui que nous
avons fait et qui fera l'objet d'une
revue technique dans les semaines qui
viennent revue technique détaillée qui
est de partir sur la technologie de
réacteur à eau pressurisé qui est bien
maîtrisé et de concevoir ce réacteur New
World avec une logique de de
père de petits réacteurs qui permettent
de bénéficier d'une facilité de monter
en cadence industrielle et d'une
compacité relative qui est souhaitée par
un certain nombre de clients
donc nous aurons dans les semaines qui
viennent une revue technique approfondie
de l'ensemble des composantes ce
réacteur au stade de la définition
préliminaire dans lequel nous sommes
avant de rentrer dans une phase de
définition plus plus précise qui
s'engagerait dans les mois qui suivent
ce type de réacteur nous sommes partis
pour ce type de rectangle nous sommes
partis sur les technologies existantes
avec le souhait de pouvoir faire le plus
vite possible parce que c'est exactement
ce qui est attendu de notre part par
l'ensemble des contacts commerciaux que
nous avons d'ores et déjà notamment à
l'international sur ce type de réacteur
j'observe que depuis deux trois ans
beaucoup de pays qui n'étaient pas dans
le nucléaire constatant que le nucléaire
est la seule technologie disponible qui
permette la décarbonation en tout temps
et ne dépendant pas de l'intermittence
la plupart de ces pays viennent au
nucléaire ou souhaitent venir au
nucléaire certains d'entre évidemment
iront directement sur des réacteurs de
Ford puissance mais prenons pas la
majorité d'entre eux d'autres pays sont
intéressés par entrer dans le nucléaire
sous la forme de réacteur de moyenne
puissance donc c'est précisément
l'objectif de ces réacteurs qui sont par
ailleurs adaptés à des usages multiples
de la chaleur et de l'électricité qui
peut voir leur jour ou correspondent à
des besoins dans plusieurs types de pays
et notamment pour les sites industriels
existants qui auraient besoin à la fois
de chaleur d'électricité pour répondre à
votre question sur les technologies il y
a évidemment dans le futur d'autres
technologies possibles qui sont basées
sur d'autres processus nucléaires mais
qui n'ont pas la même maturité technique
aujourd'hui donc si nous partons
aujourd'hui sur le pari d'un
développement en self fondue en neutrons
rapides etc nous devrions nécessairement
viser un horizon de temps beaucoup plus
long ça veut pas dire qu'on se
désintéresse de cette technologie ça
veut dire simplement pour ces
technologies qui nécessitent encore
davantage d'efforts de R&D nous allons
continuer avec nos partenaires du CEA à
travailler sur la qualification de ces
procédés nucléaires dans leur principe
même avant potentiellement un jour de se
lancer dans le développement d'un
réacteur
donc le premier objectif c'est le SMR
dans un pas de temps rapide à
technologie maîtrisée donc parce que si
j'ai bien compris new warn c'est de la
standardisation du REP mais c'est aussi
quelques
pari techno technologiques
nous on a encore éprouvé est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous regardez de
près est-ce que vous êtes prêt à le
revoir pour
accélérer la mise en disponibilité du
prototype ou pas
je vois que vous connaissez le sujet sur
le bout des doigts oui et c'est
précisément le sujet du travail que nous
avons dans les semaines qui viennent
pour qualifier la faisabilité et le
degré de risque technique que nous
prendrions ou pas sur certains
composants du réacteur parce que ces
éléments peuvent si tout se passe bien
contribuer à la faisabilité industrielle
l'accélération de la cadence de
fabrication et la compétitivité de ces
réacteurs si tout se passe mal ils
peuvent évidemment contribuer à nous
retarder sur l'accès à ce marché donc
c'est très précisément l'un des sujets
de travail collectif et de d'examen que
nous avons dans les semaines qui
viennent
dernière question cette première série
avant de laisser la parole au rapporteur
quelle est la vision dans le monde que
vous décrivez
d'un certain d'un nombre croissant de
pays qui vont demander à accéder à la
technologie nucléaire qu'elle soit
petite ou grande
du de la disponibilité de la matière ici
l'uranium et du coup du cycle du
combustible parce que les deux les deux
questions semblent intimement liées en
tout cas dans l'histoire de la stratégie
de combustible française
merci beaucoup
naturellement la disponibilité de du
cycle du combustible la disponibilité du
combustible fait partie intégrante de
l'approche de la filière et évidemment
l'aval du cycle également
nous avons la chance en France de
disponible de disposer d'une industrie
complète sur l'ensemble de ces sujets je
pense même pouvoir dire que c'est
relativement unique au monde de disposer
d'une industrie complète qui est capable
à la fois d'aller jusque dans les mines
chercher le combustible d'assurer
l'ensemble du cycle de traitement du
combustible pour le préparer à
l'utilisation et d'assurer l'ensemble de
son cyclaval donc nous avons cette
chance d'avoir une industrie complète
avec Orano et beaucoup d'autres
entreprises qui concourent au cycle
ce qui nous permet aussi d'aborder nos
partenaires potentiels avec cette vision
complète du cycle
naturellement si le nucléaire se
développait à toute vitesse ça
engendrerait des besoins sur le cycle du
campus qui nécessiteront également des
investissements ça serait le cas pour
multiplication évidemment de l'industrie
nucléaire de l'usage de l'industrie
nucléaire en Europe ou dans le monde et
je pense qu'il faut être prêt à cette
évolution
je pense qu'à ce stade nous avons grâce
à l'industrie dont nous bénéficions une
très grande robustesse de notre accès
aux combustible grâce à des sources
diversifiées dans le monde entier et des
partenariats nombreux qui permettent de
pouvoir sourcer du combustible
dans différentes dans différentes
régions du monde il faudrait continuer
d'enrichir cette approche pour une plus
grande échelle d'utilisation du
nucléaire et naturellement travail
également sur l'aval du cycle pour
s'assurer que la valse du cycle peut
être pris en compte naturellement pour
nos propres besoins et le cas échéant
pour pouvoir l'offrir comme une capacité
commerciale également qui pourrait
proposer un certain nombre de pays
partenaires de nos technologies
est-ce que est-ce que vous faites des
projections en matière de disponibilité
de la matière
minière dans la dans le cadre d'un
renouveau nucléaire mondial et donc d'un
besoin croissant qui pourrait croître de
façon très rapide à l'échelle mondiale
d'uranium
alors nous faisons d'abord nous avons
nous-mêmes avec Orano et d'autres nous
avons des engagements de long terme
on pourrait faire des parallèles entre
le marché de l'électricité et le marché
du combustible nucléaire un marché du
combustible nucléaire vous pouvez soit
l'acheter à court terme
auprès de auprès de gens qui en
disposent mais la meilleure façon de
vous sécuriser c'est quand même d'avoir
un contrat de long terme donc il y a un
parallèle intéressant avec le monde de
l'électricité donc nous avons d'ores et
déjà avec Orano et d'autres des
engagements de long terme qui portent
sur plus d'une décennie en général pour
nous assurer la disponibilité du
combustible nous avons évidemment nous
regardons de façon stratégique
l'ensemble des régions du monde qui
disposent de capacités ou qui
s'apprêtent à disposer de capacité après
le métier d'EDF n'est pas d'être le
l'entreprise minière c'est plutôt Orano
qui est le spécialiste et donc nous
discutons régulièrement avec Orano de
ces perspectives stratégiques de long
terme pour nous assurer de la
disponibilité de la réserve comme on le
fait dans n'importe quel monde minier
merci monsieur le rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président Directeur Général pour ces
premiers éléments déjà très complets
peut-être une question générale pour
commencer
vous succédez ici à de nombreux anciens
responsables de DF que nous avons
interrogé et qui ont chacun décrit un
affaiblissement progressif d'EDF même
s'ils ont eu tout ce tendance à dire que
la situation était plutôt meilleure à
leur arrivée à leur départ qu'à leur
arrivée mais on peut comprendre ces
explications parmi les éléments de
réponse qui nous ont été donnés il y a
bien sûr la reine
il y a bien sûr les signaux politiques
qui ont été envoyés l'impact sur sur
l'entreprise et certains ont évoqué les
investissements à l'international et
l'état de la filière et les relations
avec une autre entreprise bien connue
est-ce que vous souscrivez à ces raisons
principales et est-ce que vous envoyez
d'autres y compris internes à
l'entreprise sans chercher de
responsables ou de responsabilité
particulière est entendu que vous avez
annoncé récemment un endettement
financier net de plus de 60 milliards et
un résultat net du groupe de -18
milliards ce qui j'imagine est la somme
de nombreuses conséquences et aussi de
nombreuses décisions probablement
également internes à l'entreprise
je ne peux pas nier que avec les
chiffres que vous venez de citer
l'entreprise fait face à une difficulté
c'est clair on peut pas dire qu'une
entreprise qui porte ce bilan et ce
résultat sur 2022 se trouve au milieu de
sa forme donc nous avons certes une
pente forte devant nous
je crois fondamentalement que
nous pouvons la remonter c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure en propos
introductif
et je crois simplement que pour la
remontée il nous faut une prise de
conscience collective
au sein de l'entreprise et dans la façon
dont l'entreprise interagit avec
l'ensemble de ces parties prenantes
oui EDF a
construit dans les années 80 et 90 un
parc nucléaire qui a permis d'être
compétitif de fournir le métier
compétitif partout en France à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
particuliers entreprises oui EDF je
crois fait tout ce que l'entreprise peut
pour faire en sorte que elle soit au
rendez-vous de la fourniture
d'électricité tout en contenant
d'entretenir son parc nucléaire comme
tous les autres mais EDF est une
entreprise industrielle elle a aussi
des cycles et donc elle fait face à des
moments dans lesquels les besoins
changent
et donc il y a déjà 10 ans peut-être
même 15 EDF est entré dans un cycle dans
lequel
il fallait commencer à réinvestir et EDF
a commencé à réinvestir et nous sommes
maintenant au pied de la pente où il
faut le faire à plus grande échelle et
c'est ça le principal défi auquel nous
sommes confrontés donc ça est-ce que DF
peut le faire tout seul sans prise de
conscience collective je ne le crois pas
est-ce que DF peut le faire avec la
prise de conscience interne qui est que
nous devons nous remonter les manches
complètement pour faire en sorte que
notre parc produise à pleine capacité
d'une part et que d'autre part nos
projets de développement soient conduits
en temps en heure dans les budgets ça
c'est ce que EDF peut faire est-ce que
EDF en faisant juste ça peut être
couronné de succès je pense que c'est
insuffisant je pense qu'il nous faut une
prise de conscience collective qui
inclut évidemment les pouvoirs publics
dans leur ensemble et qui inclut nos
concitoyens considérant que nous sommes
à un stade où pour réussir et pour nous
amener pour l'envers plusieurs décennies
à nouveau
de performance et de compétitivité dans
la fourniture d'électricité décarbonée
nous devons accepter que oui EDF doit
pouvoir facturer son électricité
au-dessus de 42 euros du mégawattheure
pour une partie significative de ses
activités EDF doit pouvoir
contractualiser à long terme avec ses
clients dans des conditions qui sont des
conditions reflétant les coûts
économiques de long terme EDF doit
pouvoir vivre une vie d'entreprise qui
n'est pas forcément le reflet de d'une
somme de contrainte qui peuvent être
appliquées à une entreprise
qui bénéficie des attentions de tous
pour le diapositivement et donc c'est
l'ensemble de ces éléments qui doit
concourir infinie à la capacité de
rebond et d'accélération d'EDF au
bénéfice de la collectivité
je vous remercie pour votre réponse mais
c'était pas ma question je suis désolé
si j'ai pas bien compris la question ma
question c'était parmi les causes qui
ont été évoquées par vos prédécesseurs
et au vu de votre expérience c'est très
simple mais j'imagine riche depuis
quelques semaines et mois au sein d'EDF
est-ce que vous identifiez d'autres
éléments que ceux qui ont été mentionnés
la reine les signaux politiques envoyés
sur la production nucléaire les
investissements internationaux qui
expliquent la situation actuelle de
l'entreprise
oui alors pardon si si ma réponse était
pas claire mais
je pense que nous devons nous confronter
aux enjeux qui relèvent d'EDF elle-même
et donc la disponibilité du parc la
capacité de produire à plein régime la
capacité de conduire nos projets de
développement en tenant les budgets et
les délais tout ça est d'abord la
responsabilité def c'est d'abord la
nôtre
et donc ça je pense que ça répond à
votre question sur votre contrôle cette
fois-ci
évidemment mais même pour atteindre ses
objectifs là nous avons besoin d'une
prise de conscience collective parce que
derrière ces objectifs là il y a bien
sûr la mobilisation d'ef mais il y a
aussi le fait que chacun de chacun de
nos interlocuteurs chacune de nos
parties prenantes chacune des procédures
que nous devons suivre doit pouvoir
concourir à ses objectifs et c'est là
dessus que nous avons besoin d'un
changement de paradigme collectif pour
dire voilà le temps je parlais du temps
métal tout à l'heure le temps est
précieux le temps de connexion réseau
est précieux pour la collectivité et des
précieux pour EDF
temps de réalisation de nos projets et
précieux il est précieux pour la
collectivité des précieux pour EDF tout
ce qui nous permet collectivement de
travailler dans un temps plus comprimé
nous permet de gagner c'est là dessus
que nous pouvons travailler ensemble
j'espère que cette fois-ci j'ai
correctement merci justement vous avez
évoqué les contraintes auxquelles
EDF est soumise et d'ailleurs les
contraintes et les injonctions qu'on a
pu voir à ces contradictoires parfois
par le passé auquel le DEF a été soumise
il y a aussi des contraintes quasi
exogènes qui sont assez rares pour une
entreprise j'en cite deux pour vous
faire réagir la première c'est la
survenue d'un défaut générique qui
touche un très grand nombre de réacteurs
et qui vient paralyser pour un temps
même si la situation a été gérée on a
votre directeur en charge du parc
nucléaire qui nous l'a expliqué de
manière très détaillée et puis on a par
exemple le fait que la prolongation de
la durée de vie des réacteurs est
soumise à l'autorisation de l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire et que donc
par construction certains réacteurs ou
l'ensemble des réacteurs qui sont soumis
à des visites décennales peuvent ne pas
être autorisés à continuer leur
exploitation comment est-ce que
concrètement une entreprise industrielle
anticipe se prépare et gère des risques
aussi systémiques pour son outil
industriel
alors le défaut générique c'est une
hantise de toute entreprise industrielle
c'est pas spécifique à EDF
quoi que vous fabriquiez vous avez
toujours la hantise du défaut générique
simplement dans les autres entreprises
industrielles vous avez un défaut
générique vous faites un rappel
ça n'a pas les mêmes conséquences que un
défaut générique quand auquel vous êtes
confronté quand vous opérez 56 centrales
nucléaires et qu'un défaut je dirais
qu'en touche un certain nombre quand
vous fabriquez des voitures vous faites
un rappel auprès de vos clients c'est
pénible d'aller chercher des centaines
de milliers de véhicules mais vous le
voyez régulièrement dans la presse c'est
ce qui arrive quand une entreprise
industrielle d'une autre nature est
confiée confronter un défaut c'est pas
plus simple pour ces entreprises voilà
j'étais suffisamment longtemps dans
l'industrie d'un autre type moi-même
c'est pas plus simple de faire face à un
défaut génique dans une autre industrie
simplement les conséquences sont
généralement moins lourdes il y a des
entreprises qui ont été confrontées à
des défauts génériques et qui n'ont pas
survécu ça existe
il y a simplement dans le cas d'EDF
évidemment une préparation de longue
date de très longues dates je me
souviens de discussion il y a plus de 20
ans
les représentants d'EDF disaient notre
dentiste c'est le défaut générique
ajuste titre et donc rechercher en
permanence comment se préparer non
seulement à détecter de façon très très
avancée ce type de risque mais également
comment le traiter et là ce défaut
génial qui est apparu et en l'espace de
12 mois nous sommes passés de la
détection à l'identifie à la
caractérisation à l'identification des
solutions et au déploiement industriel
de la solution
je n'y suis pour rien donc je peux faire
un commentaire dessus pour une
entreprise industrielle c'est pas mal
d'être passé par ce cycle en 12 mois et
je peux vous dire que pour avoir été
dans les centrales regarder très
précisément tout ce que ça signifie
c'est vraiment une mobilisation
industrielle sans précédent donc
ça ne veut pas dire que ça ne peut le
défogénique ne peut pas arriver ça veut
dire que l'entreprise est capable de
mobiliser toute sa filière pour faire
face à un risque de ce type et un risque
de ce type fait partie du risque
industriel quel que soit l'industrie
dans laquelle vous êtes donc le deuxième
élément qui est votre question sur l'ASN
l'ASM dans ce chemin est un partenaire
pour EDF parce que même si chez EDF nous
conseillons que la sûreté c'est notre
responsabilité et ça sera toujours le
cas avoir un partenaire externe qui est
une autorité par ailleurs donc il y a la
capacité de prendre une décision de
façon totalement autonome qui a
l'ensemble des compétences et des
capacités pour comprendre ce qui se
passe ça aide l'exploitant évidemment
parce que ça permet de d'aller au bout
du diagnostic et d'avoir un deuxième
regard sur une situation donc ça ça nous
ça nous aide au total à prendre les
bonnes décisions et à pouvoir
discuter des solutions techniques avec
un partenaire et c'est vrai dans la
résolution des problèmes mais c'est vrai
et également dans la façon dont nous
abordons la prolongation de la durée de
vie parce que là pour la nation de la
durée de vie ça veut dire
fondamentalement examiner de fond en
comble chacun des réacteurs regardez
chacun des détails au sein de ces
installations relativement complexes et
de déterminer avec l'Autorité de sûreté
ce qu'il convient de moderniser de
changer etc pour permettre la
prolongation de la durée de vie en toute
sûreté
alors je prolonge ma question sur ces
sur ce point là concrètement
l'entreprise se projette comment sur la
durée de vie des réacteurs parce qu'il y
a les décisions qui seront prises
individuellement pour chaque réacteur
sur chaque sur chaque prolongation et
chaque visite décennale mais
fondamentalement j'imagine qu'une
entreprise a besoin d'avoir de la
visibilité est-ce que vous vous projetez
à une durée de vie de 50 ans 60 ans plus
de 60 ans est-ce que vous avez une
méthode probabiliste qui vous conduit à
dire que il est raisonnable de penser
qu'un certain nombre de ce réacteurs
dépasseront 60 ans et j'imagine que tout
ça a un impact sur la manière dont vous
anticipez les investissements les
investissements évidemment de
maintenance mais aussi de d'exploitation
ou de renouvellement et autrement dit
est-ce que vous anticipez les fermetures
les fermetures de réacteurs non pas des
fermetures qui seraient dû une et qui
serait dû à des décisions politiques
mais à des fins d'exploitation qui
arriveront qu'on renouvelle ou pas le
parc
alors c'est une
cette approche de la durée de vie donc
je pense que vous mentionniez 50 60
c'est sur la durée de vie complète et
pas sur 50 ans de progression quoi que
quoi
en fait c'est une c'est une méthode qui
est très qui est très pas à pas parce
que au fond chaque centrale chaque
réacteur est un objet industriel et ce
qui compte c'est notre capacité de
connaître de fond en comble de
diagnostiquer d'avoir la connaissance de
l'intimité des process et de la qualité
physique de chacun de nos réacteurs et
c'est ça infinet qui nous amènera à être
nous-mêmes convaincu de la capacité des
emmener plus loin et en cela même si
même si le nucléaire est spécifique et
qu'il dispose d'une autorité de sûreté
séparée etc ça n'est pas différent d'un
site industriel
de type C réseau etc dans un site
industriel si vous êtes opérateur
industriel d'une autre nature vous avez
la même approche fondamentalement vous
cherchez à avoir la connaissance la plus
intime possible de l'ensemble des
éléments qui constituent votre site
industriel et vous continuez de le
maintenir le moderniser pour faire en
sorte qu'il puisse durer le plus
longtemps possible et puis il y a un
moment où par exemple si vous êtes
confronté à la nécessité de changer des
éléments
les plus basiques de l'infrastructure là
à ce moment là oui effectivement la
décision peut devenir plus difficile
mais ces éléments là ces décisions là
elles ne sont pas planifiable très
longtemps à l'avance vous avez
simplement à définir une méthodologie
c'est le sujet de notre travail avec la
SN pour les mois qui viennent une
méthodologie qui nous permet de dire
voilà dans quel calendrier nous allons
examiner les différents sujets
techniques qui peuvent nous amener vers
ces prolongations
je remercie alors on parle bien sûr du
parc existant et puis il y a le la
construction de nouveau réacteurs et
bien sûr un sujet qui a été longuement
évoqué dans notre commission c'est celle
de l'EPR de Flamanville avec les
conclusions du rapport folds et puis
ensuite les recommandations qui ont été
faites et enfin la manière dont elles
ont été prises à bord pour le père de
Flamanville et puis j'imagine dans le
futur chantier des des pères
supplémentaires qui pourraient être
décider
une des questions centrales dans le
rapport fold c'était la question de la
sous-traitance une question qui a été
abordée autant par les anciens
responsables de DF que par les
organisations
représentatives que nous avons
auditionné
et le besoin d'avoir non seulement une
visibilité sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
de sous-traitance mais en plus un rang
limité dans la sous-traitance pour
éviter que on arrive à un rang 4 ou 5
dans la sous-traitance et quand donc on
perde la capacité à avoir sauf
erreur depuis 2016 et jusqu'à 2020 à peu
près le nombre d'heures de
sous-traitance au sein d'EDF
diminuait et depuis 2020 j'imagine en
partie sous le coup de la corrosion sous
contrainte dès maintenant ce qui se sont
accélérés et qui ont nécessité aussi
d'avoir en même temps un grand nombre de
de d'heures de travail ce nombre
d'heures a augmenté à nouveau quel est
votre appréciation de l'état de la
sous-traitance au sein d'EDF est-ce que
vous avez des inquiétudes sur certains
corps de métiers sur certaines tâches
qui concernent le parc nucléaire
existant et comment est-ce que vous
abordez cette question en prospectif
pour les nouveaux chantiers pour éviter
de reproduire un certain nombre de
scénarios qui ont pu avoir lieu pour le
je vous remercie de rappeler le rapport
de Jean-Marc Saint-Paul parce que je
pense que c'est un c'est un élément très
important de
du retour d'expérience de Flamanville et
de la façon dont nous structuons notre
travail pour l'avenir de la filière
alors
pour moi qui vient d'une entreprise
plutôt de type sous-traitant
la notion même de sous-traitance et
quelque chose que j'aborde plutôt sous
l'angle du partenariat c'est à dire que
quand vous regardez un chantierpr
un gentil EPA il y a des moments où vous
avez plus de 10000 personnes sur le
chantier
par définition c'est 10000 personnes
représentent des savoir-faire des corps
de métiers
parfois des compétences ou voir des
technologies qui ne peuvent pas être
résumées dans une seule entreprise donc
il faut mobiliser une filière
industrielle des corps de métiers
différents des savoir-faire différents
dans un chantier qui doit être
parfaitement orchestré c'est ça vraiment
l'enjeu principal de l'intégration d'un
grand chantier de type Flamanville et de
l'ensemble des EPR qui sont construits
et ça ça suppose que cette mobilisation
de filière soit partenariale la notion
de sous-traitance c'est celle à laquelle
on arrive finalement quand on n'a pas
organisé la filière parce que là on se
dit bon bah il me faut un soudeur il me
faut un soudeur voilà
l'objectif que nous avons c'est de faire
en sorte que nous ayons des partenaires
sur l'ensemble des coeurs de métiers et
que ces partenaires soient formés qui
soient entraînés au gestes qu'il faut
accomplir qu'ils connaissent la
dynamique de chantier qui connaissent le
contexte dans lequel Isère et à ce
moment-là nous arriverons à faire en
sorte que ces 10000 personnes
travaillent de façon plus harmonieuse et
en respectant donc mieux les délais en
évitant le refaire qui est le problème
principal auquel on est confronté dans
les chantiers complexe pas seulement
nucléaire
et c'est comme ça je crois que nous
avons nous sommes en train de prendre la
Constitution avec le gifn et avec
l'ensemble des entreprises partenaires
d'une filière beaucoup plus robuste que
ce que nous avions au moment de
Flamanville mais Flamanville a été lancé
c'était le seul chantier de construction
depuis 10 ans et pour 10 ans encore et
donc l'enjeu principal que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est de bâtir sur
Flamanville sur le retour d'expérience
d'inklepon qui est en train d'entrer
dans cette phase d'intégration intense
aujourd'hui le fait que l'apprentissage
qui aura été fait par ceux qui ont
travaillé sur l'un puis sur l'autre
puisse être transmis à l'ensemble de
ceux qui interviendront sur les
chantiers futurs donc c'est vraiment
dans cet esprit que nous comptons
adressé le point soulevé par Jean-Martin
folle sur la sous-traitance mais nous
prenons la totalité de ces points
extrêmement au sérieux et nous
travaillons sur chacun d'entre eux
j'en profite parce que vous avez parlé à
la fois dans notre propos liminaire et
ici des compétences vous estimez en
accord d'ailleurs avec la plupart des
représentants de la filière que le
besoin est de l'ordre de 10 à 15000
embauches par an considérable et encore
très au-dessus des recrutements actuels
l'entreprise ainsi que d'autres
partenaires d'ailleurs mettent en œuvre
des formations Haddock à la fois
nombreuses et puissantes avec les plans
que vous avez rappelé il n'empêche qu'on
peut être inquiet légitimement de la
capacité à atteindre ses objectifs de
recrutement y compris dans les toutes
prochaines années pour à la fois
maintenir le parc et puis construire de
nouveaux réacteurs est-ce que vous
appelez de vos vœux de la part des
pouvoirs publics une réaction ou en tout
cas un effort supplémentaire qui est pas
forcément financier d'ailleurs mais qui
peut être de communication de de
fléchage mais qui pour combler ce qui
pourrait très vite un déficit très
important comme on a pu l'observer
d'ailleurs dans les précédentes années
alors on adore et déjà un partenariat
très étroit avec les points publics
nationaux régionaux pour faire en sorte
que dans chaque région nous ayons un
plan opérationnel destiné à créer les
vocations parce que vraiment le point le
plus important c'est créer l'évocation
c'est nous avons les formations existent
ne sont pas saturées donc le plus
important c'est de créer l'évocation
donc ce plan existe il est très
ambitieux et nous avons le plein soutien
des pouvoirs publics nationaux régionaux
naturellement nous allons le conduire
dans la durée c'est un plan qui
nécessite d'être soutenu pendant
plusieurs années et qui peut créer je
pense vraiment des une filière et
d'évocation pour longtemps puisque cette
activité destinée à être soutenue pour
longtemps
voilà naturellement également
c'est pour cela que EDF doit aussi
garder une activité internationale parce
que la cyclicité de nos projets fait que
par définition nous devons pouvoir
adresser les besoins de la France avec
de temps en temps le support de colle ex
internationaux et de l'International de
temps en temps avec le soutien de
collègues français
parce que autrement notre propre
périmètre finalement est trop soumis à
des cycles pour pouvoir soutenir une
industrie donc nous devons pouvoir
soutenir notre industrie avec une
ambition qui n'est pas limitée à la
France mais évidemment qui sert les
besoins les besoins du pays
justement pour ces raisons et avant d'en
venir au marché européen deux questions
d'actualité d'une certaine manière mais
qui ont un impact sur le long terme
évidemment pour EDF et pour le la
stratégie énergétique du pays la
première sur le statut
d'EDF vous avez vous l'avez indiqué dans
vos déclarations récentes une offre
publique d'achat simplifiée a été
clôturée provisoirement avec une
acquisition du capital par l'état de
l'ordre de 96% en attente de la décision
de la Cour d'appel
récemment au sein de notre assemblée une
proposition de loi a été votée pour une
nationalisation de DF selon des
modalités que je décris pas ici puisque
vous les connaissez et elle sera
examinée au Sénat sans bien sûr vous
demander de vous prononcer quel serait
les conséquences pour votre entreprise
alors même qu'une offre publique d'achat
simplifiée est en cours et qui pourrait
se finaliser dans les prochaines
semaines moi quelle serait les
conséquences de cette législation
nouvelle si elle était adoptée
alors je suis pas complètement sûr des
conséquences juridiques de cette
législation ce que je peux dire c'est
que dans le cadre du projet doivent
public d'achat simplifié de l'État
l'état annoncé son intention de venir
actionner à 100% de DF donc des facto à
l'issue du processus de d'achat et d'une
offre publique de retraite que l'État
déposera probablement à l'issue des
procédures juridiques en cours en tout
cas même si la suspendu le déclenchement
de cette Opel ligne de retrait l'état
détiendrait très probablement 100% du
capital ce qui veut dire que nous nous
trouvions dans le statut d'une
entreprise qui voit son capital détenu à
100% par l'État et inscrit son projet
dans le cadre de la gouvernance d'une
entreprise détenue à 100% par l'État qui
élabore son projet le sommet à son
conseil d'administration et voit ensuite
son conseil d'administration guidé son
action et sa stratégie voilà le cadre
dans lequel nous sommes
je ne sais pas exactement quel serait
les conséquences juridiques sur
l'entreprise
de la proposition de loi si elle était
adoptée
ils ne sont pas qu'elle change la nature
du projet de l'entreprise
la nature du projet l'entreprise
s'inscrit aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'un
capital détenu à 100% par l'État ce qui
permet essentiellement ce que j'avais
dit lors de mes auditions de disposer
d'une vision de long terme sur sur la
façon dont l'entreprise doit dérouler
son projet
y compris sur la partie transport donc
qui pourrait être rattachée après de
manière globale comme ça
c'est là que le texte de loi lui-même
par définition je vais pas me prononcer
par le mot et souvent donc pas me
prononcer sur le Parlement doit décider
une entreprise détenue à 100% par l'État
elle reste également une entreprise donc
elle a besoin d'un peu de flexibilité
quand même donc s'il y a un texte
rigidifie la totalité de ses capacités
ça peut finir par obérer son ses
capacités d'action donc on n'est pas de
mon point de vue de chef d'entreprise
c'est une limitation qui n'est qui n'est
pas souhaitable et enfin il peut y avoir
des des dispositions qui ne sont pas du
ressort de la loi mais de textes
communautaire sur lequel le pays s'est
déjà engagé qui peuvent le cas échéant
obligé à maintenir un certain nombre de
règles spécifiques sur des activités
spécifiques dont celle que vous avez
citées
je vous remercie une autre question sur
l'actualité législative qui concerne
enfin qui a évidemment un impact
important sur notre capacité à faire
face à l'urgence énergétique du pays
dans les prochaines décennies c'est
celle de notre capacité à construire des
réacteurs nucléaires bien sûr du point
de vue industriel mais également du
point de vue de des procédures et donc
nous examinerons à partir de ce soir en
commission de développement durable et
demain comme ils sont affaires
économiques un texte d'accélération sur
le projet de loi nucléaire est-ce qu'il
entend est-ce que en tant que partie
prenante à la construction de de
nouveaux réacteurs il apporte des
solutions et il présente des limites
quant à la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs et la capacité à le faire dans
les dans les temps qui ont été annoncés
et que vous avez co prise en charge
je crois que le texte apporte le bon
état d'esprit et un certain nombre de
solutions sur l'accélération des
procédures
dans le temps que nous mettons à
construire aujourd'hui les procédures
ont pris un temps de plus en plus
important avant la construction donc
évidemment le texte est de nature à
accélérer et faciliter les procédures et
notamment à éviter l'empilement des
procédures je pense que c'est
souhaitable est-ce qu'il met des
barrières pas à ma connaissance donc je
pense que ce texte va dans la bonne
direction et reflète le bon état
d'esprit
je vous remercie enfin dernière question
non pas d'actualité mais pour essayer de
se débarrasser de certaines idées
fausses qui circulent et avoir la parole
de l'exploitant notamment sur l'uranium
enfin plus exactement sur différents
types d'uranium et sur le combustible à
la fois sur l'uranium naturel que DF
importerait encore de Russie et puis sur
l'uranium dit de retraitement enrichis
que EDF importerait de Russie est-ce que
vous pouvez nous faire 100 évidemment
dévoiler d'informations qui sont
classifiées et ou sensibles mais
simplement un état des lieux sur ces
deux points et sur la dépendance
supposée à la Russie sur ces deux points
bien sûr sans difficulté nous n'avons
pas de dépendance à l'égard de la Russie
pour ce qui est de la fourniture
d'uranium et donc du cycle de
combustible comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure nous nous fournissons auprès
de multiples fournisseurs mondiaux dont
rano bien sûr sur le sur le cycle Hamon
du combustible nous n'avons pas de
dépendance à l'égard de la Russie en la
matière nous avons un accord avec une
filiale de rosatum qui s'appelle Tenex
pour l'uranium de retraitement et il se
trouve que cette filiale de rosatum est
la seule au monde à disposition d'une
technologie de retraitement et cet
accord et
relativement ancien il n'est pas visé
par les sanctions et naturellement EDF
respecte totalement les sanctions donc
nous suivrons
aujourd'hui comme demain nous suivrons
les régimes de sanctions applicables
à la Russie et simplement pour des
raisons qu'il appartiennent aux
différents gouvernements européens et
mondiaux
ces activités ne sont pas visées par les
sanctions
je vous remercie je reviens une dernière
question sur le marché européen
forcément dans le siège des échanges que
vous avez eu avec le président
qui peuvent être prises évidemment sous
différents aspects qu'il s'agissent des
contrats de long terme il s'agissent de
la refonte complète du marché européen
ou de sa substance tel qu'il existe
peut-être pour partir au fond de de la
de la variable la plus proche de
l'économie réelle qui est celle du coût
de production et de se repositionner
dans l'idée d'une réforme du marché
européen telle qu'elle est en tout cas
réfléchie en ce moment quelle est la
position de l'exploitant EDF du
fournisseur d'électricité tout
simplement en ce qui concerne son coup
de production intégrant de manière
raisonnée à la fois la construction du
nouveau nucléaire bien sûr et puis les
investissements qui ont prêt à la
maintenance qui peuvent avoir très à
l'anticipation du démantèlement pour le
dire autrement quel est le nouveau 42
euros par mégawattheure
écoutez le 42 euros n'est pas un coup de
production c'est une décision
administrative
donc nous avons engagé un travail dès
mon arrivée pour essayer de comprendre
effectivement l'ensemble des enjeux qui
comprenaient moins bien un coup de
production pour moi c'est pas une
négociation c'est une réalité et donc je
pense que l'enjeu pour l'entreprise
c'est d'arriver à expliquer à ses
clients d'abord éventuellement aux
autorités qui nous surveillent quel est
l'enjeu réel
y compris les efforts de performance que
l'entreprise doit faire d'ailleurs sur
elle-même sur ses coûts pour ne pas ne
pas engendrer trop de coûts mais quel
est fondamentalement le chemin que nous
sommes capables de bâtir qui englobe
tout ce que vous avez listé c'est à dire
ce qui n'est nécessaire d'avoir pour
opérer nos centrales nucléaires
existantes ce qui est nécessaire d'avoir
pour les maintenir
pour les maintenir dans le sens de
prolonger leur durée de vie c'est-à-dire
en incluant le grand carénage ce qui
l'insère d'avoir pour traiter la valse
du cycle futur actuel bref voilà quand
vous prenez cette approche qui est
responsable et qui consiste à regarder
l'économie de l'ensemble de notre
filière avec une logique de continuité
d'exploitation qui est celle dans
laquelle par définition EDF s'inscrit
dans ce cas là vous arrivez avec une
économie qui évidemment n'est pas 42
euros du mégawattheure et qui est plus
proche de la façon dont l'entreprise
forme une ré librement ses prix comme
n'importe quel industriel quand vous
êtes un industriel vous connaissez vos
coûts de cours et de long terme et puis
vous formez vos prix vers vos clients en
tenant compte de ce que la concurrence
est capable de faire évidemment pour
espérer avoir au bout une petite marge
mais pas eu d'énormes marge non plus
parce que si vous avez une énorme marge
par définition vos concurrents vont
faire mieux donc ce que nous espérons
c'est d'être capable de former nos prix
à sortir d'une connaissance étroite de
l'ensemble de nos coûts économiques qui
intègrent évidemment les besoins
d'investissement dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais il est trop tôt pour moi
pour vous donner un chiffre du nouveau
42 parce que 42 encore une fois n'est
pas un coup mais une décision
administrative mais sans vous faire
trahir de secret commercial et on
comprend bien que les réflexions sont
encore en cours est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner au moins un orthographe
c'est-à-dire est-ce que vous êtes proche
du 42 mais supérieur ou finalement
est-ce que et on peut très bien le
comprendre du fait à la fois de
l'inflation de l'évolution depuis une
dizaine d'années et des investissements
qui sont nécessaires très lourds puisque
vous voyez la question et je la
rapproche du marché européen la question
qui se pose derrière y compris si on se
place dans des contrats de long terme
qui permettent de finalement sécuriser
un prix raisonnable enfin en tout cas un
prix relativement fixe pour le
consommateur qui soit industriel ou
particulier c'est que le coût enfin le
prix qui soit présenté soit un prix qui
soit certes sécurisant en cas de crise
pour ne pas se retrouver confronté au
prix qu'on découvre aujourd'hui avec les
insuffisances du marché européen mais
aussi un prix qui ne soit pas deux ou
trois fois supérieur au prix que son cap
est capable j'allais dire
malheureusement ou heureusement de
proposer le marché européen quand tout
va bien c'est à dire des prix parfois
extrêmement bas et sensiblement même on
a pu le voir inférieur aux 42 euros très
bien je comprends très bien ça alors je
voudrais commencer par dire que les prix
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas à 42 euros
prix sont un mix de ce 42 euros encore
une fois décision administrative et un
mix de marché donc les prix sont plus
proches si on prend la part énergie du
tarif régulé de vente
est à 135 à peu près
sans répondre directement à votre
question parce que je veux pas répondre
en l'air à une question comme ça il y a
trop de trous dans le jeu et trop de
travail encore nécessaire sur le sujet
je vais vous donner une indication qui
est parlante sur
au fond comment la formation d'un prix
dans un contrat de long terme est
possible et permet d'amortir le risque
de volatilité au mois de décembre dans
les petites fenêtres dans lesquelles EDF
peut faire des contrats de long terme
nous avons conclu un certain nombre de
contrats de long terme sur des activités
renouvelables avec des avec des
entreprises
le prix auquel ces contrats de long
terme a été conclu et de l'ordre de 90
euros du mégawattheure
les prix forwards à l'époque où nous
avons conclu ces
contrat était de l'ordre de 300
donc c'est pour vous dire que dans une
approche économique
d'entreprise dans lequel vous abordez
vos clients en regardant finalement ce
qui est votre anticipation en tant que
entrepreneur industriel de votre
économie sur le long terme et pour
garder le client fait de même de son
côté il y a la faculté de former des
prix qui sont beaucoup plus proches de
la réalité économique donc des coûts que
dans une approche qui est guidée
uniquement par le marché le marché étant
lui-même simplement une anticipation des
prix du gaz c'est ça la différence
fondamentale qui est entre les deux donc
c'est pour ça que nous pensons qu'il est
possible de d'améliorer la visibilité de
long terme à la fois pour les
consommateurs et pour les producteurs en
utilisant ce type d'approche et dans ce
cadre là sans répondre directement à
votre question je pense que voilà nous
sommes dans une économie qui est
compatible avec l'avenir def
merci beaucoup
à passer au députés des groupes alors
sur Maisonnais je sais pas
alors Monsieur Tanguy
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
Monsieur Raymond écoutez plusieurs
questions je voudrais revenir une
nouvelle fois sur le coup de la reine
non pas le coup actuel et négociations
sont déjà parlé le rapporterait le
président mais sur puisque ce dispositif
arrive à extinction est-ce que DF a
aggloméré pardon le Cook que ça
représentait pour cette entreprise
depuis depuis son sa mise en application
pardon pour le moment les caisses la
question que j'ai posé à vous
prédécesseur personne n'était capable de
donner une estimation du coût total de
la Reine pour le résultat d'EDF mais
aussi pour le contribuable à travers les
éventuels dividendes qui aurait pu être
verser à l'état si le résultat d'EDF
avait été meilleur vous venez de parler
du d'une part de 135 euros
megawatt-heure dans le tarif régulé
est-ce que ça correspond bon normalement
au coup enfin au coût de production
moyen ou est-ce que c'est un chiffre
différent puisque en fait j'allais vous
poser la question du coût de production
moyen de DF
est-ce que c'est ça correspond à 135
euros de la même manière
quand vous êtes arrivés à la tête de DF
dans quel état avez-vous on a beaucoup
parlé de l'état du parc nucléaire dans
quel état estimez-vous être le parc
hydroélectrique on a beaucoup parlé des
problèmes de sous-investissement qui
aurait pu être lié ou pas et d'ailleurs
on peut ce que vous avez aussi une
opinion là-dessus sur le fait que la
question juridique des concessions
n'avaient pas été finalisée ou clarifié
de telle manière que Dave puisse
investir est-ce que vous constatez aussi
que ça a été un problème est-ce que
c'est est-ce que l'État juridique la
situation juridique de ces concessions
encore un problème pour vous et sur
votre capacité d'investissement et quels
sont en fait les capacités
d'amélioration de la production
hydroélectrique nonobstant les
difficultés climatiques évidemment je
parle de de l'outil industriel de la
même manière on a beaucoup de mal à
savoir quel est le vraiment le potentiel
hydroélectrique et step en France il y a
beaucoup d'estimations très différentes
qui vont du casino d'amélioration à des
perspectives beaucoup plus intéressantes
qui sont celles que je partage pour être
transparent mais c'est une c'est une
c'est une question parfaitement ouverte
de la même manière tout autre sujet
alors c'est différent les nous posons
nous on pose une seule série de
questions généralement désolé c'est un
peu le c'est un peu une liste à la
Prévert
pour la construction du nouveau parc
nucléaire se faire de ma part
aujourd'hui nous avons seulement une
étude britannique pour inclipoint sur
l'impact du coût d'actualisation du
capital sur le prix final enfin le coût
final et le prix final de l'électricité
avec une variation extrêmement
importante pour ce qui est de l'étude de
la Cour des comptes britanniques puisque
selon le coût d'actualisation du capital
on va c'est à dire si le coût
d'actualisation est très faible on a
même appris final négatif pour peu que
c'est de la un sens économique et si le
coût d'actualisation est important on
passe les 100 euros est-ce que c'était
est-ce que cette estimation existe pour
EDF est-ce qu'il n'existe pas ce qui
risque à faire puisqu'il évidemment on a
aussi des arbitrages à faire sur la
façon dont on va financer
le nouveau parc et le coût
d'actualisation du capital le taux
d'intérêt versé semble avoir un rôle
extrêmement important compte tenu de la
densité capitaliste capitalistique de de
ces de ces constructions le rap le
président sauf erreur vous a parlé des
potentialités d'amélioration de la
production nucléaire du parc actuel en
faisant ce qu'on peut appeler du Power
pour enfin il y a pas vraiment de
traduction en France j'ai pas trop
compris votre réponse là-dessus alors je
la précise aux États-Unis alors il y a
pas d'études récentes mais il y a une
première étude de 2010 une deuxième
étude de 2014 de mémoire sur un quart du
parc américain ces opérations auraient
permis une amélioration de 7 enfin
l'équivalent de 7 tranches nucléaires à
1000 mégawatts est-ce que donc est-ce
que il y a une étude qui a été faite à
EDF sur les capacités alors je sais
qu'il y a des différents juridiques un
des différences de sécurité une
différence de disponibilité du parfum
américain par rapport au parc français
et nonobstant tous ces différences
est-ce que cette étude existe sur quand
même l'amélioration du patrimoine
pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas été fait
par mon grand carénage puisque si j'ai
se faire de ma part le grand carénage a
vraiment un aspect sécurité sûreté mais
visiblement la capacité de mélanger à
ces aspects de sûreté une amélioration
du rendement de la productivité n'a pas
été faite sauf erreur de ma part ou
mauvaise information de la même manière
l'agence intestinale de l'énergie
atomique à des estimations très
intéressantes de la hausse de rendement
avec la cause génération puisqu'on a
selon la synthèse des travaux une hausse
de rendement de 30% ce qui n'est quand
même pas négligeable de la production
nucléaire c'est la dernière c'est
l'étude de 2018 de la IEA et surtout
aussi une baisse de 35% des émissions de
chaleur compte tenu de l'importance de
ce sujet avec le réchauffement
climatique c'est pas négligeable parce
qu'ils est-ce qu'il existe des études
aujourd'hui pour EDF ou est-ce que ça
reste ça reste à faire enfin autre
question vous avez parlé des on a parlé
des contrats de long terme en uranium je
dois dire aussi que votre réponse ne m'a
pas rassuré puisque bien sûr je
comprends ce que vous avez dit sur les
contrats de long terme mais on peut
estimer qu'on rentre dans une période
aujourd'hui d'incertitude
[Musique]
merci monsieur le député
alors je reprends vos questions dans
l'ordre
le coût total de l'arène pour EDF je
j'avoue humblement que je ne sais pas
la seule ordre de grandeur que je peux
citer c'est la demande d'EDF qui fait
toujours le l'objet d'un recours
indemnitaire de 8,6 milliards d'euros
déposés par EDF en 2022 comme suite à la
décision de l'État d'augmenter le seuil
de la reine à 21
de 21
supplémentaires
alors votre deuxième question est-ce que
le 135 euros correspond au coût de
production moyen le 135 euros correspond
au tarif régulé devant
un mix annuel qui est calculé par la
Creuse sur la base des 42 euros du
mégawatt pour la cote-part qui est
fournie à l'arène
au bénéficiaire du tarif je suis désolé
si je deviens techno donc la quote-part
qui fournie à l'arène
pour les bénéficiaires du tarif
réglementé de vente et pour le reste du
tarif sur la base de estimation de
marché donc c'est un prix en fait qui
est constitué sur la base d'une
quote-part à 42 heures du médiateur le
reste étant
calculé toujours par la Creuse sur la
base de l'estimation des prix de marché
auxquels EDF comme c'est compétiteur
peuvent se sourcer sur le marché voilà
comment est constitué le 135 euros qui
est ce tarif donc réglementé sur le
contrôle de mes collaborateurs
[Musique]
le parc hydro merci de votre question
sur le pack hydro que d'abord je
voudrais saluer la disponibilité du
parking pendant pendant toute cette
année parce que comme le parc d'ailleurs
ils ont fait le l'objet d'une
disponibilité exceptionnelle
de mémoire
97%. donc vraiment pour un outil
industriel disponibilité exceptionnel
que nous avons utilisé d'ailleurs tant
bien en turbinage qu'en pompage parce
que voilà toutes les nuits de cet hiver
nous avons remonté de l'eau à un très
haut rendement pour pouvoir continuer de
disposer de la capacité hydraulique dans
la journée et c'est un des éléments qui
nous ont permis de passer l'hiver donc
très bonne disponibilité
oui nous devons travailler encore à ce
stade à la pérennisation du modèle
juridique et je ne suis pas encore au
stade où je peux vous dire quelle est la
solution que nous allons trouver du
travail tous les jours donc
je suis confiant dans le fait que nous
allons trouver une solution qui permette
la pérennité il y a un potentiel
hydraulique dans notre pays et je pense
qu'il est il est utile que nous
réexaminons le potentiel hydraulique
dans notre pays avec une optique
multi-usage d'ailleurs je discute
évidemment avec avec les présidents et
présidente de région dont celle du Sud
qui exprime une sensibilité accrue
évidemment pour la disponibilité de la
ressource en eau il y a un potentiel
dans notre pays qui n'est pas encore
totalement saturé de de gestion durable
de l'eau fondée sur sur des retenus qui
permettent le multi-usage y compris
l'ido-électricité il y a un potentiel
qui n'est pas encore totalement exploité
de pompage de STEP
estimé en tout cas pour les projets dont
EDF a connaissance à 2 gigawatts à peu
près de de puissance disponible qui ne
nécessite pas forcément d'ailleurs des
grands ouvrages puisqu'ils peuvent
simplement
être mis en place sur des ouvrages en
place avec des travaux complémentaires
donc oui il y a un potentiel
complémentaire et je pense qu'il est
utile que ce potentiel complémentaire
soit envisagé et activer dans un
contexte dans lequel la ressource en eau
se fait plus rares nous avons une année
2022 un niveau d'hydrolité très faible
nous avons un début d'année 2023 avec un
niveau de nettoyé cité qui est qui est
pas très bon non plus qui n'affecte pas
pour l'instant la quantité de
d'électricité hydroélectrique produite
mais qui qui évidemment si la sécheresse
d'hiver dure finira par affecter le
potentiel donc quand nous devons
intégrer tout cela dans une vision du de
l'hydroélectricité et des réserves en
eau et de la constitution de réserve en
eau qui qui bénéficiera je crois sur le
long terme à notre pays dans un contexte
de moindre prévisibilité des
précipitations
sur le nouveau parc vous avez raison de
se député de dire que le coût du capital
est un élément important évidemment de
la constitution des projets nucléaires
notamment dans la mesure où les projets
nucléaires mettent un temps de
construction significativement plus long
que d'autres technologies pour autant le
coût du capital peut faire l'objet de
travail dans la structuration financière
de ces projets et donc il a aussi il y a
la faculté projet après projet de
travailler sur la structure de capital
de ces projets pour faire en sorte que
ces projets ne soient pas renchés par la
structure du capital c'est l'un des
sujets sur lesquels nous travaillons
pour le financement de la série de PA2
potentiel d'amélioration de Power alors
je reviens à votre question mais je
refais ma réponse pour la rendre je
l'espère plus claire le sens de ma
réponse était bien que
dans les dans l'état actuel du parc de
DF et du niveau de production d'EDF la
façon la plus évidente et la plus rapide
d'améliorer la disponibilité et donc la
quantité de production disponible c'est
d'améliorer la coefficient de
disponibilité du parc donc ces deux
réduire les heures non-productives c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait cette réponse
d'abord parce que ça ne servirait pas à
grand chose de se lancer dans un grand
programme d'amélioration de la quantité
de puissance disponible par réacteur si
avant cela nous n'avons pas amélioré
significativement la disponibilité
temporelle de chacun des réacteurs
dans dans chacun des mois de l'année
donc notre priorité c'est de commencer
par ça pour autant évidemment on
travaille en étude sur la sur la
capacité d'améliorer la puissance
disponible par réacteur mais à ce stade
sauf erreur de ma part c'est au stade
d'études
ensuite
vous m'avez interrogé sur
la hausse du rendement avec les
cogénérations je ne prétends pas fait le
tour de toutes les études et toutes les
capacités de DF encore à ce stade mais
je pense que c'est étudié aussi parce
qu'en tout cas j'en ai entendu parler
voilà et effectivement c'est
effectivement
quelque chose qui est conforme au bon
sens même si voilà on voit on voit des
panages seulement sur un certain nombre
de réacteurs ceux qui ont des aéros
réfrigérants ça veut dire quand même
qu'il y a une énergie résiduelle qui est
qui est rejetée et donc le bon sens veut
que on puisse aller chercher cette
énergie résiduelle donc il y a des
études en cours pour voir ce que l'on
pourrait potentiellement en faire
naturellement on n'est pas dans une
phase de déploiement
sur sur l'uranium j'ai parlé des
contrats de long terme ça n'est pas la
seule façon pour nous de nous garantir
le
l'accès à l'uranium la diversification
et la meilleure protection bien sûr la
diversification des sources et la
meilleure protection mais nous avons
aussi une politique de stock qui est qui
est tout à fait qui est tout à fait
rigoureuse pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions
avoir le temps de voir venir et
éventuellement de changer de posture si
jamais une région du monde ou une
activité particulière était confrontée à
des problèmes d'approvisionnement
sur la modulation
l'impact financier à ce stade je pense
pouvoir dire qu'il est négligeable
nous avons effectivement un certain
nombre de moments dans l'année dans
lequel un peu de modulation est
nécessaire
contenu on va dire d'une séquence
particulièrement vanteuse ou
particulièrement ensoleillée dans une
phase dans lequel normalement tous les
réacteurs nucléaires sera appelés donc
ça existe est-ce que c'est significatif
à l'échelle du parc aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas en tout cas moi je n'ai pas eu
de cas significatif à l'échelle du parc
pour l'instant
est-ce que cette modulation
peut évoluer dans le temps c'est une
bonne question ça fait partie des sujets
sur lesquels nous travaillons puisque
évidemment dans l'évolution d'un mix
dans lequel il y aurait davantage de
renouvelables intermittents
il est possible que nous ayons besoin de
moduler davantage dans le futur
c'est pour ça aussi que nous regardons
avec beaucoup d'intérêts les
investissements comme les comme les
stations de pompage parce que la
situation pompage est vraiment l'outil
le plus adapté pour faire face à un
surcroît de génération de diverses
sources à un moment donné donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a toujours besoin d'un
mix de différents types d'activités dans
un parc dans un parc électrique est-ce
que ceci a un impact sur leur durée de
vie ou sur leur coût opérationnel
nous nous le regardons donc nous n'avons
pas la réponse à ce stade nous le
regardons
a priori les centrales nucléaires sont
faites pour être modules donc nous
pensons que en tout cas dans la façon
dont les centrales sont pilotées
aujourd'hui nous ne pensons pas qu'il
devrait y avoir un impact mais comme
nous aimons nous projeter vers l'avenir
en anticipant nous regardons si il peut
y avoir un impact voilà j'espère que
j'ai répondu à toutes vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur jumelles
merci président
[Musique]
l'audition est vraiment
utile précieuse merci pour la qualité et
la pression des réponses je vais essayer
de prendre un autre angle pour c'est ça
celui de ma sensibilité politique pour
compléter notre diagnostic
on a les uns des autres des explications
sur ce qui a conduit à l'affaiblissement
de la souveraineté je comprends
parfaitement les prudences oratoires qui
vous conduisent à ne pas
juger le passé
même si quelquefois il peut être utile
d'avoir une vision sur le passé pour
être présent et dans notre futur
est-ce que par exemple la question du
caractère intégré de l'entreprise
peut-être un outil utile efficace pour
être au service de cette souveraineté
première à la question
deuxième question vous avez pointé assez
précisément les besoins de financement
pour le roulement le renouvellement de
la filière nucléaire y compris pour le
développement
des EnR 51 milliards d'euros pour les
six paires de PR
en gros si on ajoute les carénages on
est autour d'eux 100 milliards
vous avez dit les gamins et prudemment
que des f2v apporter sa part sa
contribution
[Musique]
mais qu'il faudrait une prise de
conscience collective manière polie de
dire qu'il faudra donc des financements
publics pour être au service de ces
objectifs
quel est le degré d'urgence de cela
quel est le calendrier de cela et quel
est le montage idéal pour être au
service de ça parce que nous allons nous
devoir nous prononcer sur une loi
d'accélération
du nucléaire sans avoir de visibilité
du tout sur les modalités de financement
public troisième question
et comme député normand et comme député
de panglise suis sensible à cela
le besoin de renouvellement
de compétences et les enjeux
d'attractivité sur les métiers nouveaux
ils sont colossaux et il est clair que
la pose politique
subie par EDF dans le renouvellement de
savoir-faire a été préjudiciable
bon je sais que vous vous bossez vous en
avez parlé il y a des programmes etc
est-ce que la question du statut des
agents des
IEG
est un élément
consubstantiel et attractivité des
métiers concernés ou non est-ce que
c'est marginal est-ce que c'est
vous imaginez évidemment que ma question
est pas complètement sans arrière-pensée
enfin pour ne pas être redondant avec
mes collègues pas trop long
vous avez moi je trouve ça
courageux et ça rejoint je crois
désormais un diagnostic partagé par tout
le monde dit que la reine était à bout
de souffle dit qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait ouvrir un autre chemin jusque là
tout va bien
dit que tout cela devait évidemment se
faire dans un cadre européen au travail
renégocier pas de sujet là-dessus là
aussi quels sont
quel est le calendrier compatible avec
avec le projet d'entreprise
[Musique]
parce que chaque jour qui passe
c'est un endettement supplémentaire et
moi j'ai le sentiment pour rejoindre la
thématique que d'un commission que
lorsqu'on s'endette on s'affaiblit et
donc on a fait Bice à souveraineté et sa
capacité à contribuer à la souveraineté
énergétique à la souveraineté tout cours
de la France donc quels sont selon vous
le calendrier qu'il ne faudrait pas
dépasser
merci monsieur le député
le caractère intégré
[Musique]
je pense j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer de devant votre assemblée sur
ce sujet là parce qu'il y a une question
de votre part d'ailleurs sur ce sujet
voilà
[Rires]
donc je reconnais une certaine constance
écoutez ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que en trois mois d'apprentissage sur le
terrain dans l'entreprise j'ai vu
opérationnellement les différents
métiers de l'entreprise concourir la
capacité
d'élaborer un
élaborer et de délivrer la mission d'un
opérateur de système électrique robuste
voilà ce que j'ai vu deuxième élément
dont je crois j'avais fait part lors de
mon audition c'est que il se trouve que
ça fait une dizaine d'années que j'opère
dans le secteur électrique on va dire au
sens large et
j'ai eu la chance de le faire dans plus
d'une soixantaine de pays
j'ai vu des régions du monde avec un
système électrique qui évolue
probablement plus vite et différemment
de ce que pour l'instant le système
électrique européen a pu connaître vers
plus de décentralisation
vers plus d'automatisation même si nous
avons un système électrique très
automatisé
vers plus d'intégration entre les
besoins des clients et les capacités des
producteurs et des réseaux tout ça dans
des régions du monde qui sont moins
équipées finalement que nous le sommes
et dans toutes ces évolutions vers
lesquelles je crois nous allons aller
pas exactement de la même façon mais en
tout cas dans la même direction et j'en
veux pour preuve les augmentations de
raccordement que nous avons la part de
nos concitoyens professionnels et
particuliers qui veulent passer en
autoconsommation
ces éléments là appellent un système
électrique piloter intégré à des
compétences qui ont capables de
travailler ensemble entre depuis la très
grosse centrale de très fortes
puissances jusqu'à la capacité de
dialoguer avec une PME une TPE ou un
particulier dans la faculté d'apporter
juste la bonne quantité d'électricité
nécessaire par rapport à ses besoins
sachant que ce client aura lui-même des
facultés électriques ce monde là qui est
notre monde de presque demain qui
accélère à toute vitesse en France alors
qu'il a accéléré dans d'autres régions
du monde à toute vitesse ce monde là
nécessite encore plus d'intégration
opérationnelle voilà ma conviction de
praticien et donc c'est la réponse que
je fais également à nos collaborateurs
quand il me pose la question
sur le financement du renouvellement le
sens de ma réponse n'était pas
nécessairement dire qu'il faudrait les
financements publics
le sens de ma réponse était de dire que
au fond l'entreprise doit pouvoir former
des prix qui représentent son économie
et si elle est capable de faire ça elle
permettra de financer sa continuité
d'exploitation il peut y avoir des
limitations financières
en fonction de l'ampleur du programme
d'investissement que nous devons
considérer ces limitations financière
elles sont plus associées à la taille du
bilan de la taille de la dette qu'il
faudrait lever pour faire tout ça quelle
est la capacité économique de lever
l'ensemble de ces financements donc
c'est dans cet esprit que nous avons
évidemment discussion avec les pouvoirs
publics que nous avons eu ces
discussions dans d'autres pays du monde
vous avez peut-être vu que en 2022 après
avoir
porté depuis le début
projet inclipoint
par le bilan d'EDF nous avons conclu un
accord avec le gouvernement britannique
cet accord avec le gouvernement
britannique sur size wellc prévoit le
développement de deux réacteurs
supplémentaires avec le gouvernement
britannique comme partenaire financier
et avec un accord de mode de financement
de ce développement donc et il y a un
certain nombre de projets européens dans
plusieurs pays d'Europe dans lequel à
chaque fois des modalités spécifiques
d'associations des pouvoirs publics sont
discutés et sont le cas échéant
lorsqu'on parle d'Europe communautaire
sont le cas échéant présentés à la
commission européenne pour vérifier leur
compatibilité avec les communautaires
donc il est trop tôt pour dire
exactement quels seront les modalités
mais dans notre cas l'élément précurseur
finalement c'est de pouvoir dire sur la
base de nos opérations actuelles
faisons en sorte que notre économie
permette la continuité de l'exploitation
durable ce qui inclut évidemment le
renouvellement de notre parc existant
voilà voilà l'esprit de ma réponse
sur les compétences
quand je ne ferai pas l'injure de vous
dire
ce qu'il faut sur le sur un chantier en
Normandie vous le savez parfaitement
sur les 10000 personnes qui sont
nécessaires au moment de la phase
d'intégration la plus critique sur un
chantier de pair il y a pas 10 000
personnes def
voilà et voilà et donc
que le statut des agents
IEG soit un élément
d'attachement très fort
de la part de l'ensemble des
collaborateurs des Ig nul doute c'est
clair
que soit un élément d'attractivité
je pense qu'on peut le dire parce que ça
fait partie de l'identité
à laquelle les
salariés d'EDF et de la branche sont
attachés est-ce que pour autant sur les
milliers d'autres qui sont nécessaires
pour concourir au développement de
projet de cette nature le statut
représente quelque chose non en général
ce sont des gens qui viennent et qui
appartiennent à des conventions
collectives aussi diversifiées que celle
de la métallurgie celle de celle du
saint-eg etc parce que ils apportent des
corps de métiers différents en réalité
et c'est justement l'agglomération de
toutes ces compétences et de ses corps
des métiers différents sur un seul
chantier qui permet le succès de le
succès de l'entreprise donc voilà
j'espère que j'ai répondu à votre
question sur le statut néanmoins
le calendrier pour la reine
écoutez nous avons un cadre fixé par une
décision
enfin pas une décision communautaire
relevant d'une proposition française qui
a mis en place la reine en 2012 cette
décision court jusque fin 2025
nous avons par ailleurs une discussion
communautaire en cours sur les règles de
marché faisant suite à la consultation
lancée par la Commission européenne la
commission ayant annoncé l'intention de
proposer
au ministre de l'énergie dans les jours
qui viennent
puis très probablement au sommet
européen dans les semaines qui viennent
les modalités futures d'organisation du
marché d'électricité je pense que ce
calendrier immédiat nous va bien à nous
EDF parce qu'évidemment il est de nature
à éclairer la route devant pour savoir
quels sont les choses qui pourraient
changer dans le domaine de
l'organisation de marché et donc
évidemment nous sommes extrêmement
attentifs à ces discussions et en
fonction de ces discussions évidemment
nous
nous naviguerons comme un opérateur
européen qui qui agit dans le cadre des
règles qui lui sont fixées voilà
j'espère que j'ai répondu à vos
questions
alors je vais me faire le porte-parole
de Marie-Noëlle batistel qui est député
de l'Isère et membre de notre commission
qui a suivi
assidûment les travaux de notre
commission et qui malheureusement est
retenu par une autre grande entreprise
française
qui consomment beaucoup d'électricité
voilà
alors
un de vos grands clients voilà
deux questions que je me permets de
relayer une première qui vient
finalement approfondir ce sur quoi vous
avez digéré répondu quelle est la vision
de l'intégration des énergies
renouvelables dans un groupe EDF 100 %
nationalisé et plus particulièrement de
l'hydroélectricité et seconde question
plus locale concernant la souveraineté
et la nécessité de produire en France
pour ne pas être dépendant des Chinois
notamment en matière photovoltaïque
comment voyez-vous l'intégration de
l'entreprise
iserroise Photowatt au sein du groupe
EDF nationalisé ou à défaut son avenir à
l'extérieur elle précise que les
salariés vivent dans l'incertitude
depuis de trop nombreuses années et que
cette entreprise a toute sa place dans
la création d'une vraie filière
française
d'autant que le silicium composant
important est produit également en Isère
merci beaucoup pour monsieur le
Président pour la question madame
baptistel sur l'intégration des énergies
renouvelables
je reviens à la réponse que j'ai fait au
député jumelles
pour pour être couronné dessus un
opérateur comme EDF a besoin d'être
performant dans un mix énergétique et le
mix énergétique il est d'autant plus
nécessaire que
nous devons dans le futur avoir de plus
en plus de production des carbonées que
les différents moyens de production des
carbonées non pas les mêmes
caractéristiques en termes de
temporalité notamment nous avons
l'éolien et le solaire qui sont
intermittents l'hydroélectrique qui est
soit au fil de l'eau soit commandable
quand il est commandable il peut
contribuer à l'équilibre du réseau avec
une mobilisation à très court terme
quand il est associé à une station de
pompage il peut même contribuer à
retirer d'électricité qui serait
surnommé l'air dans le réseau et donc
c'est bien de l'ensemble de ces
caractéristiques là qu'un opérateur
comme EDF a besoin il y a besoin d'être
performant dans chacune d'entre elles
pour pouvoir rendre le service qui est
attendu par nos concitoyens et donc nous
continuerons évidemment
d'agir dans le secteur des renouvelables
comme nous le faisons dans les autres
technologies et j'ajoute même que pour
être pertinent dans le domaine des
renouvelables il faut pouvoir l'être à
l'échelle internationale pour avoir la
bonne échelle d'activité et amener en
France les compétences et les
technologies nécessaires
ce qui fait un lien avec la question
d'après concernant Photowatt donc
Photowatt est une entreprise
qui a été reprise par EDF
et que EDF continue de soutenir
naturellement
pour rendre une filière photovoltaïque
performante en Europe il faut une
mobilisation européenne
et pour venir moi même du secteur des
technologies je sais par expérience que
dans un certain nombre de technologies
dans lesquelles seuls une région du
monde a fait un effort massif pour créer
un appareil industriel de très grande
taille destiné à servir le monde entier
la seule façon de contrecarrer cette
formation et de mettre un effort massif
équivalent en face qu'à ce jour je pense
seuls les États-Unis ont engagé donc
il n'appartient pas de déterminer si
c'est souhaitable ou nécessaire à
l'échelle européenne je dis simplement
que en l'absence d'un téléport massif à
l'échelle européenne il sera pas
possible de transformer
la petite entreprise Photowatt qui
travaille avec EDF et qui continue de
développer son activité dans un cadre
limité en un champion du solaire
photovoltaïque mondial parce que pour
arriver à faire cela il faut vraiment un
plan européen de une grande taille donc
ça fait partie des réflexions qui des
souhaitables d'avoir maintenant je suis
bien conscient qu'il y a de nombreuses
technologies candidates pour attirer les
efforts collectifs dans le domaine de
l'électrification des usages bien sûr
les modules solaires photovoltaïques en
sont 1 mais en petite télépathie on peut
citer les batteries de véhicule on peut
citer et donc surtout ces sujets
naturellement il y a des enjeux
stratégiques sur lesquels les acteurs
européens doivent se positionner dans
notre cas voilà nous portons la filière
nucléaire et nous emportons l'industrie
aussi et nous sommes la seule entreprise
en Europe apporter la filière et son
industrie
c'est déjà beaucoup pour pour un
opérateur électrique nous essayons de le
faire bien nous continuerons d'essayer
de le faire bien si nous pouvons
contribuer plus modestement à d'autres
filières industrielles ne seront heureux
de le faire mais nous ne seront pas en
mesure de le porter seul
merci ce qui est d'autres questions je
vous en prie
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le PDG de DF vous avez dirigé l'entité
française de la banque américaine qui a
notamment
conseiller Alstom lors de la vente à
General Electric en 2014
des actifs particulièrement stratégiques
ont été vendues à un groupe américain
notamment sur la branche énergie
puisque entre autres cela concernait la
maintenance et la construction la
production des turbines qui équipent nos
centrales nucléaires j'aurais donc deux
questions d'une part alors
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes PDG du
principal groupe énergétique français
qui est sur le point donc d'être
intégralement nationalisé est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que pour assurer
notre indépendance énergétique dont vous
avez parlé et que vous avez à juste
titre vanté et bien la France doit
disposer de sa propre industrie
nucléaire et notamment pour et notamment
doit favoriser des sous-traitants et des
partenaires économiques
français et ma deuxième question c'est
pouvez-vous nous dire si dans le cadre
justement de cette vente de la branche
énergie d'Alstom à l'Américain général
électrique vous avez été rémunéré et si
oui le cas échéant quel était le montant
de cette rémunération je rappelle malgré
tout que dans le cadre de cette vente et
bien général électrique c'était engagé à
créer près de 1000 emplois et que
malheureusement 8 ans après ce ne sont
pas mis l'emploi qui ont été créés mais
bien plus de 1200 emplois qui ont été
supprimés je vous remercie
si Monsieur le Député je reconnais une
question que j'avais déjà entendu
parce que j'avais été coupé
donc je vais venir sur le fond d'abord
puis ensuite bien sûr je vais répondre à
votre question
sur le fond vous allez dans l'industrie
c'est bien d'avoir une d'avoir
l'histoire du coup c'est très
intéressant d'avoir la perspective de
votre commission d'enquête et c'est bien
d'avoir la mémoire aussi sur le long
terme de ce que sont les activités
industrielles
les activités turbines du Opal stom
ont été celles qui ont failli provoquer
la mort de l'ensemble du groupe Alstom
en 2003
pour un défaut générique
ce défaut générique porté sur les
turbines GT 24 26 venant de d'une
acquisition faite auprès du groupe ABB
avec probablement je ne sais pas mais
probablement des ce qu'on appelle
communément des dieux diligence
incomplètes sur la qualité du turbine
qui avait été acheté ce turbine était
instable et ne tenait pas le cycle je
suis désolé si je devais un technique
tenez pas le cycle donc tous les clients
très grande majorité des clients qui
avaient acheté ces turbine se sont
retourné vers Alstom qui avait acheté
cette activité en disant maintenant il
faut me dédommager et donc vous imaginez
des centaines et des centaines de
turbines à gaz fournissant des centaines
de gigawatts au total
tout d'un coup se retournant vers
l'industriel qui avait fourni ces
turbines même si ce n'était pas Alstom
c'était ABB à l'époque et disons bah
maintenant il faut dédommager à coups de
milliards d'euros
donc ce cette activité là dans Alstom a
repris la qualité en faisant le même
genre de travail que ce qu'a fait EDF
depuis un an c'est-à-dire en allant
vraiment chercher les experts et en
travaillant industriellement sur les
activités qu'il venaient d'acheter
Alstom a pu redresser son activité et
avec le concours de l'État à l'époque
stabilisé l'activité et arriver à
soutenir son activité sur les années
suivantes
ça fait l'objet évidemment d'une
négociation très longue avec la
Commission européenne à l'époque pour
être état si bien que Alstom est sorti
de cette période
quand même un peu affaibli sur le métier
des turbines en général je parle pas du
turbine à vapeur je parle vraiment du
métier de turbine à gaz
s'en suivent le reste de la décennie
2010 dans lequel progressivement le
métier des turbines en général commence
à plonger à l'échelle mondiale pas
seulement chez Alstom c'est l'ensemble
du marché qui poste crise financière
n'avait plus de commande et ne vivait
plus que de la base installée parce
qu'on construit simplement plus de
turbine à gaz dans toute cette phase là
donc arrive donc 10 ans plus tard le
moment où Alstom est confronté au fait
de devoir trouver un avenir finalement à
l'ensemble du groupe Alstom à nouveau
après une décennie d'un marché qui
n'était pas porteur qui n'était de plus
devenu porteurs et dans lequel sa propre
technologie avait été affaiblie
Alstom était confronté à un choix
cornélien certes comme les industriels
peuvent l'être régulièrement en disant
qu'est-ce que je fais ce soit soit je
garde cette activité mais cette activité
va finir provoquer la difficulté de
l'ensemble du groupe à nouveau soit je
cherche une solution pour cette activité
voilà décision à laquelle était
confrontée
Alstom a cherché des solutions pendant
un certain temps plusieurs et la seule
qui est apparue réaliste parce qu'il
faut qu'elle soit réalise sur le plan
industriel vous pouvez pas vendre une
activité de turbine à quelqu'un qui n'y
connaît rien il faut que ce soit
quelqu'un qui soit capable d'acheter
cette activité et d'en faire quelque
chose et à cette époque là
le sol est le plus réaliste qui est
apparu pour reprendre cette activité
dans son ensemble donc ça incluait
évidemment les autres activités qui
étaient associées à la production
d'électricité parce qu'il faut un
ensemble cohérent et la distribution la
transmission d'électricité aussi
d'ailleurs à cette époque là était
général électrique générique était le
leader de ce marché donc voilà les
raisons qui ont amené Alstom à
considérer la vente à de général
électrique je rappelle quand même que le
générique c'est pas n'importe qui en
France général électrique c'est le
partenaire de plus de 50 ans de safran
c'est celui qui a accepté la
constitution d'une
Givet à 55 ans
avec l'entreprise française détenue par
l'État
capable de produire les moteurs civils
et militaires donc c'est pas n'importe
qui en France non plus donc il y a rien
de choquant vu d'Alstom allez voir
General Electric qui est un partenaire
historique de la France et un industrie
de reconnu dans le secteur pour dire
voilà vous êtes leader de ce marché vous
êtes sachant sur le plan technologique
dans cette activité moi Alstom je n'ai
plus les reins assez solides pour
soutenir cette activité dans un marché
qui a baissé très significativement donc
est-ce que vous pouvez considérer d'être
le prochain actionnaire de cette
activité
voilà les raisons qui ont conduit à
approcher général électrique
j'en viens à mon rôle maintenant puisque
vous m'avez posé la question laquelle je
n'avais pas pu répondre lors de mon
audition en novembre
j'ai été
j'étais effectivement directeur général
de la filiale de banque américaine à
l'époque j'étais sollicité par Alstom
pour les accompagner dans la recherche
de solutions et pour être au contact
pour amener au contact de général
électrique il se trouve que c'est arrivé
quelques semaines à peine avant que je
change d'activité parce que j'ai quitté
quelques semaines plus tard la banque
pour rejoindre Schneider Electric
voilà et donc je n'ai pas eu de
rémunération pour cette activité
voilà j'espère que j'ai répondu à votre
question cette fois-ci la première
c'était pardon
alors bien sûr oui pardon
oui pardon j'ai fait un long
développement pour revenir sur J mais
maintenant je peux répondre du coup à
votre question donc l'activité de
turbine à vapeur
comme vous le savez un turbine Arabel
donc associé à la partie secondaire du
de nos centrales nucléaires nous sommes
dans une phase finale d'acquisition nous
avons encore nous avons l'autorisation à
obtenir pour qu'elle rejoignent le
groupe EDF ce qui nous amènera quand
même à disposer des technologies clés à
la fois sur l'îlot nucléaire et sur
l'îlot conventionnel donc c'est une
façon d'avoir l'ensemble des
technologies cœur pour pour l'ensemble
des deux éléments qui contribuent à la
formation d'une centrale nucléaire
est-ce qu'il faut pour autant que EDF
intègre la totalité des technologies non
je pense que c'est d'abord ça serait pas
de bonne gestion parce que nous avons
besoin d'enrichissement technologique
par des entreprises qui ne sont pas
exclusivement dans le nucléaire nous
avons besoin de savoir-faire qui
viennent d'autres industries pour
nourrir nos propres savoir-faire et donc
nous nous accueillons volontiers dans
notre
dans notre filière des entreprises qui
sont pour une part seulement dans leur
nucléaire qui apprennent le nucléaire
avec nous mais qui apportent un
enrichissement technologique un
enrichissement de savoir-faire qui ne
serait pas exclusivement associée au
nucléaire
j'espère que j'ai répondu à toutes vos
questions cette fois-ci c'est bien
monsieur jumelles rapidement
merci de la réponse que vous avez
apporté sur du compte la loi votée en
première lecture à l'Assemblée qui ne
modifie pas grand chose
des projets d'EDF en matière de
récapitalisation d'autant que
elle risque d'être votée par le Sénat et
je vous annonce qu'on la reprendra à
l'Assemblée dans des délais rapides dans
le cadre de la niche de mon groupe mais
je voulais vous interpeller sur deux
sujets que j'ai oublié tout à l'heure
dans le cadre de la loi accélération du
nucléaire
j'envisage
apparemment ou en tout cas par
questionnement
d'interroger le gouvernement sur la
nécessité que qui ne un contrôle public
un contrôle Parlement des investisseurs
étrangers
susceptibles d'intervenir dans le
domaine du nucléaire on parle de
souveraineté est-ce que la question de
la participation d'investisseurs
étrangers à la production nucléaire est
un sujet pour vous deuxième question
dont nos territoires respectifs les
exemples ne manquent pas
dans l'aéronautique dans le militaire de
sous-traitants qui ont été tellement
fragilisés tellement asphyxier que ça
aboutit à leur délocalisations dans des
pays autres que la France
et quelquefois ça dépend entier de
souveraineté industriels qui sont j'ai
des exemples avec thalène et des
exemples avec Safran
en Normandie du coup est-ce que cette
réflexion là du rapport entre EDF et ses
sous-traitants de manière à les
maintenir
robustesse suffisante pour préserver des
plans de souveraineté industrielle au
plan national et quelque chose qui
rentre dans les réflexions que vous avez
engagé dans votre nouvelle gouvernance
merci beaucoup pour pour vos questions
monsieur le député je pense que dans le
premier cas
je m'éloigne de mon champ de compétence
mais je vais faire appel à des très
vieux souvenirs
il me semble que
sur la base des textes existants
le gouvernement adore et déjà la faculté
d'examiner
des investissements étrangers dans des
activités qui qui peuvent
potentiellement toucher à la
souveraineté
voilà il me semble que c'est le cas et
je sais par expérience que le
gouvernement fait usage donc il y a
effectivement analyse examen
technique détaillé sur le type de
dépendance que ça peut créer le type de
le type de transfert potentiellement que
ça peut créer voilà ceci existe voilà
après il est parti au Parlement au
gouvernement déterminé ce qui relève de
la compétence du Parlement et du
gouvernement j'ai attiré juste votre
attention sur un élément c'est que
tout ceci doit se passer dans le temps
de l'entreprise
et le pire pour une entreprise c'est de
rester en lévitation voilà donc dès lors
qu'on s'inscrit dans le temps de
l'entreprise je pense que les
instruments existent et avec par
expérience un professionnelisme avéré de
la part des
services gouvernementaux qui travaillent
sur ces sujets là sont à la fois des
techniciens et des juristes qui sont
capables d'écrire une
décision spécifique permettant
d'encadrer très précisément un type
d'activité et en même temps de
comprendre précisément et d'aller
chercher les expertises nécessaires pour
comprendre les enjeux industriels
associés à chaque type
à chaque type de d'activités donc ceci
existe et c'est pratiqué
ensuite sur
sur ce que vous évoquiez sur les sur les
sous-traitants et leur et leur entre
guillemets dépendance ou indépendance si
j'ai bien compris votre question
ce que je peux vous dire c'est il me
semble que notre enjeu collectif pour la
filière à ce stade et plus de
si nous arrivons à faire ce qui est
attendu de nous
c'est d'être capable de répondre
suffisamment à la demande et de le faire
de façon robuste rapide et en qualité
le problème que vous décrivez il a
existé quand la filière était dans une
phase détale ou effectivement un certain
nombre de compétences clés ne trouvez
plus dans leur activité
récurrentes de quoi soutenir leur
compétences leurs compétences
fondamentales ça a pu exister évidemment
quand vous êtes dans une phase dans
laquelle
pendant quelques années il n'y a pas de
réacteurs en construction évidemment les
compétences associées à la construction
de réacteurs elle s'étiole et donc pour
les petites entreprises des moyennes
entreprises qui concourraient à ça le
fait de pouvoir rester robuste dans ces
phases là était plus critique je pense
nous changeons de problèmes aujourd'hui
le problème auquel nous allons être
confronté c'est de faire en sorte que
chacune des entreprises concernées
puissent grossir assez vite pour être
capable de faire face aux enjeux de
développement auxquels nous sommes
confrontés ça veut pas dire que le sujet
ne doit pas être traité par ailleurs
voilà mais donc on change un peu de
nature de problème voilà voilà la nature
de ma réponse naturellement bien sûr une
des façons et je l'avais déjà évoqué une
des façons de de limiter ce risque c'est
bien sûr d'emmener notre écosystème à
l'étranger parce que à partir du moment
où
et là c'est plutôt le DF1 industriel qui
parle que le DF opérateur électrique
quand nous allons à l'étranger nous
vendons une prestation nous vendons une
technologie nous vendons un réacteur ou
l'ensemble du dispositif qui est associé
et donc évidemment à chaque fois que
nous réalisons cela
nous emmenons une grande partie de notre
écosystème industriel et nous
travaillons avec un écosystème
industriel local et le fait de faire ça
ça consolide notre écosystème industriel
parce que on travaille du coup sur un
détail de marché qui est supérieur à ce
que nous pourrions faire en travaillant
uniquement à l'échelle française
donc c'est pour ça que je ne vois pas de
contradiction même si à chaque fois
qu'on va l'étranger évidemment faut
mesurer nos risques mais moi je ne vois
pas de contradiction entre le fait de
travailler sur des projets étrangers et
le fait d'être performant en France
mon expérience industrielle elle m'a
toujours dit à chaque fois que je peux
structurer plus durablement sur un
marché plus grand
notre activité je rends notre activité
plus robuste et c'est bien dans cet
esprit qu'on essaie de travailler avec
notre filière
merci alors j'aurai une dernière
question
qui aurait peut-être pu être la première
quel est quel est le scénario en matière
de besoin électrique alors tant en
matière d'énergie que de puissance sur
lequel vous vous projetez aujourd'hui
pour construire les capacités de
production dont la France aura demain
besoin
vous voulez des centaines de
terrawateurs vous le voulez en scène en
centaines de terrain je lis en puissance
et un énergie donc en gigawatt et en TT
je pense que
nous nous plaçons
je vais pas vous donner un chiffre en
terre à water parce que ce que je trouve
vraiment je l'avais dit je pense lors de
mes auditions le travail fait par le RTE
sur la projection à 2050 est vraiment de
qualité il est fait c'est un travail
économétrique de qualité parce qu'il
analyse les besoins en électrification
des usages les besoins et les
possibilités en efficacité énergétique
les différentes technologies pour la
mairie de propre
et en balayant différents scénarios qui
permettent de voir ce qui se passe en
fonction du développement des différents
scénarios parce que c'est là c'est comme
ça que ça se construit en réalité ça se
construit pas à pas avec des
déploiements de scénario qui vont
dépendre à la fois de la demande et de
la constitution d'une offre qui sera
multi technologique là là où j'ai des
convictions fortes c'est sur le fait que
la demande électrique va augmenter
parce que nous sommes encore à ce stade
sauf
erreur de ma part en dessous de 30% ou
tout juste à 30% en cas de la France
mais en dessous de 30%
d'énergie
électrique par rapport à total de
l'énergie consommée donc nous avons
quand même un besoin d'électrification
qui est encore encore tout à fait
significatif en commençant bien sûr par
les transports mais une partie du
bâtiment aussi et que les objectifs de
décarbonation sans électrification
supplémentaire seront extrêmement
difficiles à atteindre donc je pense que
ce qui se passe sous tendre ce scénario
électrique de long terme et
par nécessité une électrification plus
importante des usages et que pour
satisfaire un tel scénario
il nous faut je crois réaliser le plus
possible de toutes les technologies
c'est une conclusion assez simple en
réalité c'est que le temps est contre
nous et pour répondre à ce scénario
d'électrification des usages et de
décarbonation de l'ensemble de
l'économie européenne il nous faut
investir le plus possible dans
l'ensemble des moyens de production des
carbonées
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président dans le siège de votre
question je pose ma question autrement
la la
les dernières annonces ont permis de
constater que en accord avec la filière
est donc en partie j'imagine avec EDF la
question se posait non pas seulement de
construire trois paires de réacteurs
supplémentaires mais potentiellement qui
n'avait huit autres en réflexion et donc
il y en avait une quinzaine à l'horizon
2050 qui était envisagée et qui donc
j'imagine était
possible de la part constructible de la
part de la filière est-ce que ce nombre
est figé à la hausse c'est-à-dire ou à
la baisse est-ce que est-ce qu'il est
envisageable
d'aller plus loin non pas à l'année près
et aux nombreux prêts évidemment à
savoir si c'est 14 ou 15 et 2049 ou 2050
évidemment je plongerai pas dans le
ridicule de poser une question de ce
type et il faudrait des études très
approfondies pour les avoir mais dans
votre projection de consommation et à
l'inverse de production est-ce que il
est envisageable d'aller au-delà à
nouveau pas à l'année près et pas aux
chiffres près de cette quinzaine de
réacteurs à l'horizon 2050 c'est-à-dire
si les plannings étaient respectés pour
les premières réacteurs et donc si la
capacité industrielle de produire ce
type de tranche était enclenché est-ce
qu'il serait possible d'aller plus loin
à l'horizon 2050 55 60
alors je vais je vais vous répondre en
deux éléments le premier c'est que
la seule certitude que nous ayons à ce
stade c'est que la performance de nos
anciens qui est tout à fait réel
puisqu'ils ont réussi à construire à 58
réacteurs en 20 ans
elle finira par nous rattraper
donc il y a un moment
quand nous aurons fait tous nos efforts
possibles de prolongation en toute
sûreté des réacteurs existants il y a un
moment où le fait que nos anciens est
vraiment très bien travaillé en étant
capable de déployer 58 réacteurs en 20
ans ça va nous rattraper parce que à un
moment ils vont tous tomber en 20 ans
peut-être un peu plus
donc il nous faut préparer une montée en
cadence
pour nous rapprocher le plus possible de
la performance de nos anciens le jour où
nous aurons besoin d'égaler nos anciens
en tout cas nous en rapprocher
si nous pouvons formuler cette ambition
donc c'est le premier élément
à ce jour je ne sais pas vous dire quand
ce sera nécessaire puisque évidemment ce
qui a de plus rationnel aujourd'hui
c'est quand même de continuer de
travailler le plus efficacement et avec
une logique de sûreté à la prolongation
du parc existant
ma deuxième réponse c'est que l'enjeu
principal pour être capable de faire une
montée en puissance telle que celle que
vous décrivez qui peut devenir
nécessaire à un certain stade c'est
d'être capable de sortir le réacteur
récurrent le plus vite possible et sans
tout refaire c'est vraiment l'enjeu
principal et donc c'est celui sur lequel
nous allons focaliser toute la tension
def si nous sommes capables de dire que
peut-être pas le premier e PR2 mais le
troisième
devient notre référence de coût
récurrent délai récurrent capacité
d'aller vite
je sais bien que le député Jumet
préférait que ce soit le premier ou le
deuxième mais
donc nous ferons notre mieux sur le
premier et le deuxième monsieur le
député évidemment évidemment mais il y a
toujours du gain de productivité on est
dans de l'industrie donc il y a toujours
un gain de productivité à attendre donc
tout l'enjeu pour être capable de
répondre oui à votre question c'est de
focaliser toute la tension toutes
l'énergie de DF et de la filière pour
faire en sorte que sur la série de six
dont nous parlons nous atteignons
l'effet de palier comme comme on le dit
chez EDF et que nous ayons la capacité
de construire des réacteurs de façon
récurrente en vitesse avec une avec une
chaîne industrielle qui est habituée à
la série et la chaîne industrielle c'est
évidemment tous ceux qui fabriquent des
éléments qui rentrent à l'intérieur des
réacteurs commencez par Framatome bien
sûr mais évidemment toute une cascade
l'industrielle qui travaille avec
Framatome avec EDF mais c'est également
la capacité de mobiliser 10 000
personnes quelque part qui savent déjà
comment intégrer un réacteur et qui
n'ont pas à réapprendre
qui n'ont pas à redécouvrir à nouveau le
processus d'intégration qui est un des
éléments les plus critiques aujourd'hui
que nous avons vécu à la fois sur
Flamanville et nous sommes en train
d'entrer dans cette phase qu'il a pu la
plus difficile à inclipoint voilà les
éléments sur lesquels nous devons
consacrer notre attention toute la
tension de DF et de la filière pour
répondre positivement pardon à votre
question mais si nous y arrivons
c'est pour être capable de le faire
voilà
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Directeur Général pour votre
disponibilité devant notre commission
d'enquête nous conclurons d'ici à la fin
de la semaine les travaux d'audition
que nous avons débuté au mois d'octobre
nous aurons encore ensuite deux
auditions contextuelles et attendu des
deux derniers présidents de la
République et nous devrons ensuite
rendre nos travaux d'ici à la fin du
mois de mars tout début du mois d'avril
voilà donc merci beaucoup d'avoir
éclairé et donner un peu de perspective
à ce que pourront être les conclusions
de nos travaux je vous souhaite à toutes
et à tous une belle soirée merci
monsieur le Président merci à toutes et
à tous